Ostelektronische Musik, so Reinhard Laconi und Konsorten, die halt irgendwie sich in Kraftwerk und sonstigen Sachen orientiert haben, die waren teilweise gar nicht so schlecht, aber sowas wie Techno gab es meistens nicht.
Na ja, er ist 1199 mal e-Spam aufgetreten und hat mit Tonwintern gescratcht.
Na ja, tra...
Er ist bei 1199 aufgetreten?
Echt?
Das war ja so, das war für uns, als West Ham natürlich e-Spam auch mitgekriegt und so, das war auch ganz toll, so ja, der macht das mit Tapes und so und ey guck mal, die haben halt irgendwie nicht so viel Platten und deswegen muss er und so. Ja, West Ham, East Ham, Chaosradio, hier rufen total viele Leute an, also ihr müsst jetzt ein bisschen entscheiden, wollt ihr reden, oder? Dann wird jetzt noch ein bisschen über eure, reden wir eigentlich nur über Computer oder über andere Technologien auch?
Genau, über andere Technologien, ja, also auch über Telefone und über Kassettenrekorder und was ist das? Genau, Anrufbeantworter und was sonst noch so an Technik gab.
Ich bin dann gespannt auf die Unterschiede. Mal gucken, weißt du, wer hier dran haben, wen wir hier dran haben. Hi, hier ist Chaosradio. Moin, Lutze, machst du mal deinen Radolizer?
Hab ich jetzt gemacht.
Ah, supi, klingt schon besser. Lutze, was war dein erster Kontakt mit Computern im Osten?
Im Osten, das war der übliche.
Ja, wie ist der? Keine Ahnung, KR, noch was? Wo die Kassetten eigentlich konntest.
Welche Provenienz denn nun? Weißt du nicht, welche Nummer der hatte?
Hörst du uns?
Ich höre dich noch.
Ah ja, nur mich, die anderen nicht. Frank, sag mal nochmal was.
Welche Nummer hatte denn dieser Kc? Hallo? Ich glaube, ihr hört uns nicht.
Der hört doch nicht.
Ach so, ja, welche Nummer hatte denn dein Kc, dein Computer?
Kassette 80 oder was, kann das sein?
Das ist nochmal die falsche Nummer zwischen zwei möglichen.
Ich weiß es nicht. Ich hab den damals, ihr habt noch, wie, da konntest du Kassette mal einschieben, dann konntest du damit abspielen und alles sowas. Nee, den haben wir mir irgendwie geschenkt gekriegt, weil wir keine mehr haben, das war 90. Da waren richtig noch lustige Spiele drauf, von wegen Igel und Hase und sowas.
Aber du hast da sozusagen keinen wirklich intensiven Kontakt mit gehabt mit dem Gerät.
Wie bitte?
Du hast sozusagen keinen wirklich intensiven Kontakt mit dem Gerät gehabt.
Ja, Lutz, was ist denn deine Geschichte dann zum Thema Ostcomputer?
Ostcomputer, dass es einfach lustige Spiele waren, das war noch mit Sinn.
Wenn du heute siehst, von wegen hier Panzerfahren und Leute abschießen, kannst du verjessen.
Damals war das mit Spaß und Maus und Igel und so weiter.
Das war Hase und Igel, sowas.
Also vor der Enten abschießen.
Das war das heute.
Ich meine, wenn die Leute sich in den Computer sitzen und so eine Scheiße spielen, dann will ich nicht.
Also du meinst, die Spiele waren besser.
Aber es gibt ja heute. Aber ansonsten habe ich mit dem Computer nichts zu tun, weil ich kann nur mit Bestandsfungen, ist ich nicht.
Lutz, danke.
Noch eben, wenn du mal einen richtig geilen Osttele spielen wolltest, dann spielst du auf dem Schleimcam Attafelspiel-RFD.
Danke dir.
Haben wir das hier, Frank?
Schleimcam haben wir. Mal gucken, ob wir das haben, was wir brauchen.
Ist das ein richtig geiler Titel?
Naja, so Garagen-Punk.
Glaube ich.
Chaosradio hier.
Hallo, wer ist denn da?
Hallo?
Gelust.
Schade, ich habe noch ein Osttelefon.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio, wer ist denn da?
Ja, hier ist Jens, hallo.
Jens, hallo.
Ja, ihr wolltet wissen, was RadarBars ist?
Genau. Also du kannst deine Original-RadarBars-Lizenz gewinnen, wenn du es weißt.
Was für ein Ding?
Wir haben noch eine Original-Lizenz RadarBars, wie man beschreiben will, aus deinen Beständen.
Naja, ich glaube, die brauche ich gar nicht, aber ich dachte...
Trotzdem...
das digitale Datenbankbetriebssystem für Mikrocomputer aus dem VE, will Kombinat Robotron.
Und, ähm, weiter?
Was, noch weiter?
Jetzt gibt es natürlich die allentscheidende Frage. Datenbankbetriebssystem, das klingt natürlich so nach Technik und Lochstreifen sehe ich vor mir. Was hätte das denn sein können, so im Westen, vielleicht als Pendant oder war das zu irgendwas kompatibel? Man wollte es ja schon ein bisschen schwierig machen.
Naja, man kann da zum Beispiel da irgendwie so mit D-Base programmieren und so. Hab ich das noch in Erinnerung?
Ziemlich heiß.
Ziemlich heiß? Ziemlich heiß.
Du bist nah dran.
Welche Versionen D-Base?
Na, ich hab das mal gemacht.
Was hast du denn damit gemacht?
Ich höre euch so schlecht.
Ja, was hast du denn damit gemacht?
Wir hören uns alle schlecht irgendwie.
Du hast so eine Datenbankprogramme da geschrieben, wo du dann irgendwie so irgendwelche Messdaten da abspeichern konntest und sowas.
Wo hast du das gemacht?
Ja, in einer Firma hier in Berlin. Ich glaube, die gibt es nicht mehr.
Wie hieß die denn?
Da gibt es so einen Club, der heißt Elektro-Kohle. Die Firma auch. Ja.
Und auf was für einem PC oder was auch immer hast du das gemacht?
Auf einem Personalcomputer so. Also am Anfang hatten die alle diese ekelhaft grünen Buchstaben.
A 7150?
Kann sein, aber später gab es den dann auch schon in Farbe.
Das wird eine interessante Sendung, Ec.
Einer sagt, Ec 1837 und vier andere, ne drei andere Leute machen, 34, Entschuldigung, vier andere Leute machen. Und ich sitze hier und mache ein blödes Gesicht.
Diesen Robotron, 1715 oder sowas, kann das sein?
PC 1715, das war so dieser Standard DDR-Personalkomputer, so ein z80-basiertes Gerät mit 64 Kilobyte RAM und CPM.
Dann habe ich auch mal was mit so einem Kc gemacht. Jetzt frage ich nicht wieder nach der Nummer. Ich glaube 85-1 oder 2 kann das sein.
Der war dann kleiner und schwarz oder grob und braun?
Der war schwarz und hatte so eine grauen Tasten, die waren wie aus Gummifasten gewesen.
Was hast du damit gemacht?
Hab ich basic programmiert.
Irgendwas Sinnvolles oder nur so zum Spaß?
Ja, zum Teil auch was Sinnvolles, zum Teil auch Spaß. Und dann hab ich mir noch einen ganz tollen Westcomputer besorgt für Ostmark.
Was für ein Ding.
War es das ein ZX 81 gewesen?
Hey, hey, und wie hast du den besorgt?
Den hab ich über eine Anzeige in der Westzeitschrift, war das nun wieder verdammt. Funkamateur? Funkamateur kann sein. Da bin ich extra bis nach Plauen ins Vogtland gefahren, hab da irgendwie 1000 Mark oder 2000 Mark Ost hingeblättert.
Wann war das?
Naja, das war so schätzungsweise 1987, so rum in der Zeit etwa. Das ist hier so einer mit so einer Folientastatur, und den hab ich dann an meinen Ost-Schwarz-Weiß-Fernseher angeschlossen. Dazu brauchst du noch einen Kassetten-Rekorder, wie gesagt für diese Kassetten, um die Programme einzulesen. Naja, und da hab ich dann auch so ein bisschen Basic-Rom programmiert. Das war ja wieder etwas anders, das Basic, das war ja das West-Basics. Das war also anders als das, was auf den Ostcomputern lief. Also die waren ja auch untereinander überhaupt nicht kompatibel oder so.
Ja, gut.
Das war der Vorteil. Okay, also so weit meine Geschichte dazu.
Ja, willst du die Redawass-Lizenz haben? Willst du die Redawass-Lizenz haben? Gut, dann ist sie noch weiter auf dem Stack. Für Leute, die uns noch mehr über Redawass erzählen können. Vielleicht lustige Geschichten, die sie hatten.
Apropos Zeitschriften, gab es denn so was wie Computerzeitschriften oder waren das dann so Funkgeschichten?
Na ja, der Funkamateur war so der, das Leib und Magenblatt des DDR-Computeramateurs, wie es damals hieß. Weil da war hinten ein großer kleiner Zeigenteil dran. Und ansonsten verteilten sich so die Computersachen meistens auf die Elektronikzeitschriften. Und zum Schluss, ich glaube ab 88 gab es dann eine Zeitung, die hieß MP Mikroprozessertechnik. Die war sogar schon mit einem bunten Schutzumschlag und so und auf etwas weißerem Papier gedruckt.
Und die hatte ich glaube ich sogar abonniert.
Ja stimmt, genau, die hatte ich glaube ich auch abonniert. Die war sau teuer am Klin. Aber da war halt die erste DDR-Computerzeit. Und die gab es sogar glaube ich bis 1990 oder so.
Und diese Nummern hinter den Computern, ich meine die behaupten ja immer, das macht irgendeinen Sinn. Welchen Sinn hat das bei diesen Geräten gemacht? 85 war vielleicht das Jahr oder was?
Na ja, es gab im Osten zwei Serien von so Sachen, drei Serien, die man als Heimcomputer bezeichnen könnte. Angefangen hat es alles mit dem LC 80. Das war so eine A4-Blatt große Platine, wo hat man so eine Platine bekommen. Da waren halt lauter Chips drauf und so eine Siebensegment-Anzeigen. Und unten war so ein aufgelöteter Taschenrechner, der als Tastatur diente. Und dann konnte man dieses Ding programmieren, hatte so ein paar Schnittstellen, wo man halt irgendwas mit steuern konnte oder so. Das war so der erste erhältliche Computer. Da kam so ein Plaste-Heft da drin. Da war halt diese A4-Seite so drin. Und da konnte man dann auch irgendwie die Sachen speichern. Ich glaube damals irgendwie noch im RAM nur und später noch auf Kassette. Und dann fingen gleichzeitig bei Robotron und im VBL Mikroelektronik Mühlhausen die Entwicklung von Homecomputern an. Und da sind dann halt zwei inkompatible Serien von Homecomputern rausgekommen, die von Robotron hießen, so Kc 85 1, Z 9001 und Kc 87. Und waren weitestgehend so dasselbe Gerät. Und die waren eigentlich ziemlich scheiße, insbesondere deswegen war halt der... Also diese Serie zeichnen sich dadurch aus, dass das Ding so ein grauer Kasten war, so ein Pult mit so schlitzförmigen Tasten. Und irgendwie die Reset-Taste hatten so mitten auf die Tastatur oben drauf gemacht, dass man immer rauf kam, wenn man nicht aufgepasst hat. Und das Ding war richtig scheiße, vor allen Dingen war es super langsam. Naja, und dann gab es noch die Kc 85 234-Serie, die wohl halt in Mühlhausen gefertigt ist. Das waren so schwarze Kisten, die hatten schon Erweiterungsmodule, die sogar funktionierten und eine abgesetzte Tastatur, die wurde über so einen Klinkenstecker angeschlossen und hatte irgendwie eine ziemlich hohe Fehlerrate. Und damit konnte man schon richtig bunte Grafik machen, mit immerhin 24 Farben, also nicht 24-bit wie heute, sondern 16 Vordergrund.
Aber jeweils eine eine Farbe für 8 Pixel.
Genau, 8 mal 4 Pixel.
Stimmt, also eine halbe Buchstabe.
Ja, da konntest du halt die Farbe ändern. Und die Dinger waren dann, naja, ursprünglich waren sie tatsächlich als Heimcomputer geplant, das dann stellte sich raus, dass irgendwie alle Schulen, Universitäten, sonstige Jugendorganisationen halt irgendwie massiven Bedarf überhaupt an Computern hatten. Und dann wurde dann halt aus dem ursprünglichen Hc 900, wie der Urahn dieser Mühlhausener Serie hieß, dann halt der Kc 85234, die dann halt so nach und nach weiterentwickelt wurden. Der Kauf legt später noch drauf. Und die wurden dann halt in so einem Pionierpalast zum Beispiel. Da gab es dann halt diese Computerkabinette, wo dann halt so irgendwie so einen Haufen Computer stand. Und dann gab es diese Arbeitsgemeinschaften, wo man sich dann mühsam über sein Mathematiklehrer anmelden konnte und dann halt da in schlechtem Basis programmieren konnte. Und naja, und so haben halt viele Leute halt ihren ersten Kontakt mit dem Computer bekommen. So, also außerhalb der schon beschriebenen grauen Ankaufszene für Westcomputer, die dann halt irgendwie zu hohen Preisen im Osten verkauft werden.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, Schweinepreise. Wir hören nach dem Fritz-Info mehr über Osttechnologien, über Ostcomputer, aber auch über andere Technologien des Ostens.
Und ich bin schon mal da. Und ich bin schon mal da. Kurz Info. Sie wollte damit ihre für heute geplante Abschiebung aus Deutschland verhindern. Die etwa 20 Kurden verließen am Abend freiwillig das Gelände. Luftbrücke. Die UNO hat die ersten rwandischen Flüchtlinge aus Ostsair ausgeflogen, darunter viele Waisen Kinder. Insgesamt sollen fast 100.000 Menschen wieder in ihrer Heimat gebracht werden. Dem US-Sonderbeauftragten für Sair gelang es indessen ein Treffen zwischen Staatschef Mobuto und Rebellenführer Kabila zu vereinbaren. Die Begegnung ist für Freitag auf einem Kriegsschiff in internationalen Gewässern geplant. Urteil der Aufmarsch der Rechtsextremen NPD zum 1. Mai in Leipzig ist endgültig verboten worden. Das sächsische Oberverwaltungsgericht lehnte am Abend eine Beschwerde der Partei ab. Zuvor hatte die Stadt Leipzig die Kundgebung untersagt, weil sie Ausschreitungen befürchtet. Vereinbarung der VW-Konzern hat sich bereit erklärt, befristet 400 neue Mitarbeiter einzustellen. Die Gewerkschaft akzeptierte im Gegenzug, dass die Löhne 10 Prozent unter dem bisherigen Niveau liegen. Notbremse in der Stadt Brandenburg ist eine Haushaltsperre verhängt worden. Ausgenommen sind notwendige Ausgaben wie zum Beispiel Sozialhilfe, aber auch die Gelder für die Kinder- und Jugendarbeit. Fußball in einem Qualifikationsspiel zur Weltmeisterschaft 1998 gewann Deutschland gegen die Ukraine mit 2 zu 0. Heute Nacht kaum Regen bei 9 bis 5 Grad, morgen zunächst stark bewölkt, später teils heiter, Temperaturen um 15 bis 18 Grad. A 10 in Richtung Dreieck Werder zwischen Lest und Föbenstau an einer Baustelle, die letzte freie Ausfahrt ist Potsdam Nord.
Herr Kötterhangrich mit dem Kurz-Kurz-Info. Geri, kannst du meinen Fernseher ausmachen?
Mach ich sofort.
Ah, verdammt, hier ist er.
Hier spricht Bretzl Göring von Stereo Total.
Ich griech Froszeweskeksüß.
Hallo, wir sind gerade in der Schweiz.
Samstag, 3.
Mai im Waschhaus.
Das ist schön zu wissen, dass ich Schlager... Der große Himmel war grau, trübe und grau.
Für drei Stunden im Himmel blauer Travant.
Danke Lutz.
Aber das ist doch nett, Schlager ist ja wirklich null Unterschied, oder? Die Reime so, der Himmel war grau, ich aber froher. Schöner sagt es einfach. Muss man einfach mal so akzeptieren. Chaosradio hier, der Chaoscomputer, Blumen auf Fritz. Wir reden über Osttechnologie und spielen Ostmusik. Und ihr lacht immer so schön. Ist das so ein Lachen, was man natürlich hat bei alten Technologien grundsätzlich? Also wenn man heute über einen C 64 redet, dann schmunzelt man ja auch, wie man mit den Datasetten umgehen musste und so ein Kram. Ist das so ein Schmunzeln, oder ist das schon noch ein anderes Schmunzeln, wenn ihr es von diesen Maschinen hört?
Na ja, das ist schon so ein Schmunzeln, weil wenn man so überlegt, wie sich die Technik entwickelt hat, dann ist es eigentlich schon ziemlich lustig, wie ihr das angefangen habt.
Also es war schon so, dass wenn ihr diese Kisten damals hattet, dass das das Höchste war. Also das war einfach klasse, oder?
Na ja, Westcomputer waren schon doch irgendwie eine Errungenschaft. Also das hatte halt nicht jeder. Da gab es halt auch obstruße Beschaffungswege, irgendwie, wie die Dinge ins Land kamen. Erzähl doch darüber mal ein bisschen.
Wie ist man an Westcomputer gekommen?
Ja genau, da wollten wir eigentlich auch, dass vielleicht von euch jemand anruft. Und zwar, wie sind die Computer halt ins Land gekommen? Und eine Frage, wenn von euch jemand vielleicht beim damaligen DDR toll gearbeitet hat und uns genauere Auskunft darüber geben konnte, was denn seinerzeit nun wirklich offiziell erlaubt war und was nicht erlaubt war, in die DDR einzuführen in Computertechnik. Denn da gab es wohl nie eine offizielle Liste. Es war immer eine graue Zone und man wusste halt nie im Vorrein, ob man den Computer durch den Zoll gekommen hat oder auch nicht.
Das wäre interessant. Wenn jemand beim Zoll war, der uns ein bisschen mehr das Näheres sagen kann, darüber bitte anrufen. Übrigens habe ich noch nicht einmal die Nummer gesagt und trotzdem sind alle Leitungen belegt. 0331 für Potsdam 7481110 und jetzt reden wir erstmal mit Boris 28. Hi Boris. Du wolltest noch was zum Thema Rederbass sagen.
Ja, also Rederbass war im Prinzip ein relationales Datenbanksystem. Man konnte damit Datenbanken programmieren, so wie das war das Äquivalent zum DBS 2 damals aus dem Westen. Wahrscheinlich sogar eine Raubkopie.
Der Kandidat hat 100 Punkte.
Ja, es war eine Raubkopie. Es gab auch einige peinliche Zwischenfälle, wo auf der Leipziger Messe die Leute von Ashtentate, denen damals noch DBS gehörte, auf den Robotron-Stand kamen und darum warten, kurz einen Blick auf die Software werfen zu dürfen, ihren Disassembler anschmissen, da reingucken und an bestimmten Stellen noch Spuren ihres eigenen Kurzfandens, den die halt einfach da überarbeitet haben. Also diese Kopiergeschichte war ein generelles Kennzeichen von DDR-Computertechnologie, also die allermeisten Sachen wurden entweder direkt kopiert oder nachentwickelt, genau äquivalent zu den Sachen, die im Westen waren.
Woher weißt du sowas, Boris?
Ja, ich hab das damals selber programmiert. Ich hab damals ein Praktikum gemacht, vor dem Studium und hab dann auf dem BC 5120 oder BC 5130, das waren die älteren Bürokomputer bei uns, selber programmiert da drinnen. Es war recht lustig, man konnte damals nur 64 Varianten vergeben, also sehr programmiert, da wüsste ich auch, was das bedeutet. War eine recht lustige Geschichte.
Und jetzt nochmal für alle, also dieses Reder-Basen, was hast du gerade gesagt?
Relationales Datenbanksystem.
Relationales Datenbanksystem, das macht ja auch vom Wort her Sinn. Das war eine Raubkopie von DBS 2, die man ein bisschen umgemodelt hat und dann verkauft hat. Was hat sowas gekostet, die Software?
Na die konntest du als Privatperson nicht wirklich kaufen. Es war eine Software, die für Betriebe bilanziert werden konnte. Im Osten gab es diese Sachen mit dem Software kaufen auch nicht wirklich. Die Betriebe haben zwar getan, aber wenn überhaupt eine Kopie, und meistens hat man sich dann von Kollegen besorgt. Es gab in der DDR praktisch kaum Möglichkeiten, legales Software zu kaufen. Deswegen war alles, für Westcomputer schon gar nicht natürlich, war alles sogenannte Raubkopie. Also in der DDR war der Umgang mit Software doch noch ein ganz anderer, als er heute immer zu propagiert wurde. Aber auch unterschied sich nicht wirklich von dem, was heute so läuft.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, man kann es heute kaufen, aber eigentlich ist es auch nicht anders. Ja, Räderbarslizenz willst du haben?
Ja klar, warum nicht?
Cool, dann hinterlässt du dir irgendwie deinen Namen, Adress und so weiter? Ja klar.
Willst du jemanden grüßen?
Ich grüße alle User vom Stadtnet, die zurzeit online sind und Fritz hören.
Vom Stadtnet? Okay, ja, schick mal einen Gruß raus. Bist du online, IHC oder so? Übrigens, ja, bleibt noch am Apparat, Boris, ich schreib gleich deine Adresse auf. Bis dann, danke dir. Übrigens, für alle, die uns e-mailen, wollen die vor der Kiste sitzen, das geht natürlich auch. Die Adresse ist wie immer chaos.orb.de und Chaos, um das noch mal zu sagen, schreibt sich CHOS. Ich weiß nicht, ob andere Schreibweisen ankommen. Ich glaube nicht. So, Boris, warte noch ein bisschen. Wir reden mal mit Robert. Du sitzt gerade vor deinem Rechner, Robert?
Hallo, Robert?
Robert? Aber schade, Robert hat nämlich eigentlich gesagt, dass er gerade vor seinem Ec 1834 sitzt.
Robert, dann ruf bitte nochmal an.
Robert?
Er ist nicht dran, komisch. Hat vielleicht aufgegeben. Dann versuchen wir es mit Jenny. Hallo?
Also, ich wollte euch was erzählen über einen Kc 87 III.
Einen Kc 87 III gab es nicht.
Oder Kc 85 III? Gut, dann nehmen wir den Kc 85 III.
Ja, aber der löst hier Verzücken aus.
Also erzähl deine Geschichte.
Na ja, vor allem wollte ich auch noch fragen, und zwar lief die Spiele doch früher mal über Kassette und so weiter. Ob ich da nicht irgendwie mal so eine Rundfrage starten kann, ob jemand ein bestimmtes Spiel hat?
Klar, kannst du machen. Was suchst du?
Udo. Also das Spiel hieß Udo, das war irgendwie so ein Männchen, das da immer so durch ein Haus ging und Türen und verschiedene Spiele hinter den Türen und so.
Na ja, vielleicht dazu noch ein Wort. Es gibt mittlerweile für den Kc 85 III einen Emulator für den PC. Ja, und zwar ein kleines Software, die startet dann auf seinem PC und dann hat man ein Fenster mit einem Kc 85-3. Und da kriegt man im Internet mittlerweile richtig viel Software, praktisch alle Spiele und Sachen, die mir bekannt waren, habe ich im Internet wiedergefunden. Die konnte man sich dann in diesen Emulator leiten und tatsächlich spielen. Und es macht sogar richtig Spaß. Vor allen Dingen ist es viel schneller als damals der Kc.
Wir haben ja auch Kassetten, weil sie sonst zu Hause liegen, aber irgendwie an Udo kamen sie richtig an.
Jenny, dann machen wir das doch einfach so. Du bleibst jetzt auch gleich kurz am Apparat. Wir nehmen Boris Adresse auf und schreibt dann eine Telefonnummer auf. Und wenn sich jemand meldet, der Udo hat, dann tauscht ihr euch irgendwie aus.
Ah, klasse.
Bis gleich. So, jetzt müssen alle wieder Musik... Eie, hab ich jetzt eigentlich noch... Wo war denn Boris, verdammt?
Boris wolltest du ablegen.
Ah, du hast Boris? Ach so, gut, du schreibst die Adresse auf? Super, Gary hilft, super. Ja, Jenny, bleibst auch dran, soll mal Musik, damit ich das aufschreiben kann. Der Werkzeugsong von Panko aus dem Jahr 1982. Übrigens, ihr hört Chaosradio, den Chaoscomputer Blue Moon bei Fritz. Es geht um Osttechnologie, deswegen auch Ostmusik, Chaoscomputer Club im Studio und blöde Fragen von mir. Ich heiße Jonny und jetzt ist Robert am Apparat. Hallo Robert. Endlich. Tut mir leid, dass gerade was nicht geklappt hat.
Ja, ist eigentlich nicht so wild, ich meine.
Wir sind ja hier auch aus Technologie.
Der ESA PC kann ja warten.
Du hast noch einen Originalbetriebsbereit.
Ja, der ist vor mir und gerade leuchtet mir so der Öffnungsbildschirm vom RIDA was 3 entgegen. Ausgabe 1.1.88 und der steht schon so seit ein paar Jahren in meinem Zimmer. Und ja, und ist immer noch so mein Textprogramm, also.
Du arbeitest ja auch mit der?
Ja, also Starfighter, ich weiß nicht, ob es irgendein, ich weiß nicht über welche Wege das auf den PC gekommen ist, aber Starfighter ist immer noch so ein, also weiß nicht mal Programm, Datenbank und Textverarbeitung halt noch.
Ja, das muss man vielleicht für die unangeweihten Hörer sagen, die Ec 1834 war der erste in der DDR verfügbare IBM-kompatible Computer. Das war sozusagen der erste A-T und X-T. Und der läuft also mit dem PC-Version 3.3, also ich weiß nicht, Robocop T von MS-DOS 3.1.
Ja, das war halt auch der erste, der richtig funktioniert. Also in der Theorie ging das hier mit dem A-7150 auch schon, aber halt...
Ja, stimmt.
Theorie.
Und das heißt, da kannst du dann auch, weil ich dich fragen wollte, wie du da druckst, aber das hat sich dann wahrscheinlich erübrigt, da waren dann auch ganz normale Ausgänge dran und so.
Ja, das ist ganz normal.
Also ich weiß nicht, bloß die Ausgänge für die Tastatur und den Monitoren sind halt ein bisschen robotronmäßig.
Ja, die Stecker im Osten waren halt irgendwie komplett anders als im Westen. Da gab es so krippische...
Ja, das war aber ansonsten ganz normal das Laufwerk, also 720 und......und ein 40er-Platte und...
Das ist ja schon richtig die Luxus-Ausführung.
Wo hast du denn her?
Na ja, mein Vater hat damals, weiß nicht, das würde man jetzt vielleicht als Rechnungshof bezeichnen, also ich weiß nicht, bei der ABI, also Arbeiterbau und so. Und ja, in der Softwareabteilung gearbeitet und ja, und das letzte Konkurs mal sozusagen vorher und ich weiß nicht, im Keller bei uns steht noch so ein 1715 und auf dem hab ich da auch noch, weiß nicht, als ich meinen Vater halt ab und zu mal besucht hab und so auf Arbeit, dann halt zuerst dann eben 1715 gesessen und so und doch mal so den ersten, naja, weiß nicht, das war noch nicht der erste Kontakt. Der erste Kontakt war halt mit Kc 85 1 im Pionierpark, da Wohlheide und dann später halt dann Informatik, also Arbeitsgruppen Informatik, das muss so Mitte der 18er Jahre gewesen sein, dann halt auf dem Kc 85 3 und dort halt die ersten Programmiersersuche mit basic und so und dann halt dann mal den PC 1715 kennengelernt mit seinen beziehenden zwei Laufwerken und den riesen, weiß nicht, also die umständliche Bedienung dann halt. Und dann halt die Sensation als erstes Mal an den Ec 1834 gesehen hab, richtig farbig und so.
Hast ja sozusagen eine richtig typische DDR-Computer-Karriere hinter dir.
Ja, und das erste Faszinierende war also, ich hab den ersten Mal gesehen so um einen Subwitch, ich weiß nicht, kennt ihr das noch?
Subwitch, das war so ein, also dort im Ministerium, man denkt natürlich, die Leute arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten, dabei haben die dann auch nur als Herdnurkomputer da erst mal nur gespielt. Und hatten dann halt so eine kleine Fuchsumulation, also ganz einfach und so.
Welche Sprache sprecht ihr gerade?
Wovon reden die hier?
Ja, gut, schön, dass du angerufen hast. Ist doch wunderschön zu hören, dass es immer noch Leute gibt, die diese Geräte irgendwie in Ehren halten und damit auch noch arbeiten. Ich meine, es ist immerhin robust. Wie viele Jahre ist es jetzt her, dass der letzte EC 1834 gebaut wurde? Mittlerweile wohl sechs Jahre.
Sieben, glaube ich, bis heute.
Aber ich hatte mal probiert, MSO 500 drauf laufen zu lassen, aber es hat gar nicht funktioniert.
Na, ist ja ein Extälter, befürchtest du das fünf nicht, aber...
Sag mal, ich lese sehr hier, wenn in Potsdam immer die Plakate für so Computerbörsen und so, wird dann da auch mit so alten Material gehandelt und werden da Programme ausgetauscht? Weiß das jemand von euch?
Also es gibt, den haben wir bei unseren Recherchen gefunden für diese Sendung, es gibt einen Computer Club, der sich noch mit KCs beschäftigt und die Dinge halt pflegt und da so neue Software für schreibt, irgendwie in allen, in größtem Umfang, da wird halt eine PC-Maus ran gestrickt, ein neues Betriebssystem dafür geschrieben, irgendwie ein neuer Floppy-Controller gebaut und Krönung aller Dinge, sogar einen Festplatten-Controller entwickelt, damit man halt irgendwie seine Kc-Programme auf Festplatte speichern kann. Und die sind dann auch herbe bei der Sache und haben wohl auch diesen Kc-Emulator mit initiiert. Und so auf den Flohmärkten, soweit ich das gesehen habe, findet man immer mal wieder irgendwelche Rodimente, die halt irgendwo rausgeflogen sind, aber so richtig vollständig funktionsfähige Anlagen finden wir eigentlich selten, oder was sagt der Sender?
Ja, das braucht auch nicht wirklich jemand heutzutage, denn wirklich 5-6 Jahre alte Westgeräte, die ungefähr 5-10 Mal höher in der Leistung angesiedelt waren, gibt es heute auf jedem Flohmarkt für 10 Mark. Dementsprechend hat keiner wirklich das Interesse an den meistens 20-30 Kilo schweren Gussreisern im DDR-Kostüm.
Ja, deswegen ja auch in der Trikot historisch vollkommen uninteressant, Alex, ne? Und bei der Gelegenheit hier von wegen, wir reden hier mal von Kc 85-Emulatorn, bevor jetzt gleich 1000 Leute anrufen, wo kriegen wir den? Weil das hat auch hier im unmittelbaren Bekanntenkreis erst mal helle Begeisterung aufgelöst. Wir werden versuchen nach der Sendung zumindest die wichtigsten Links mal auf unsere Chaosradio-Seiten im World Wide Web abzulegen, www.ccc.de und darunter. Und wenn auch im Laufe der, wenn du noch weiter Input kommst, werden wir versuchen, das dann noch unterzubringen.
Lutz hat doch auch erzählt, wir haben irgendwas in die Mailbox gestellt, ne? Das ist nicht der Emulator auch?
Nein, in der Mailbox gab es ein paar Sachen, die an uns geschickt wurden, halt unter anderem so schon.
Nee, die Fritz-Mailbox. Wir haben auch noch eine Mailbox hier, nicht nur die Webpages. Und ich glaube, Lutz hat da diesen Emulator auch abgelegt. Jetzt muss ich natürlich die Mailbox nochmal gleich noch aufschicken. Ich sag euch das gleiche alles nochmal. So, es gibt auch noch Leute, die damit arbeiten, mit den etwas älteren Technologien. Warum auch nicht, wenn es funktioniert? Robert, hi.
Hallo.
Du arbeitest, nein, dein erster Ostcomputer war ein Z 1013.
Genau, mit einem U 880 D.
Und zwar nicht die Ausschussproduktion mit 1 MHz, sondern mit 2 MHz Parkfrequenz.
Naja, du weißt, dass der U 880 sozusagen nicht allein auf dem Mr. DDR gewachsen war. Moment, es ist nicht der Z 80 abgewandelt, da gibt es eine ganz amüsante Geschichte zu. Und zwar sind mir, ich glaube 1987 durch Zufall, die Unterlagen für den Z 80 in die Hände gefallen, und zwar die genauen Assembler-Programmierungsanweisungen, und zwar inklusive der illegalen Opcodes. Also da gab es halt Beidkombinationen in den Befehlen im Assembler, die theoretisch nicht im Handbuch standen, die aber was machten, also die tatsächlich sinnvolle Befehle waren. Und dann haben wir die halt auf dem U 880 ausprobiert und siehe da, sie liefen. Also es handelt sich sozusagen nicht um eine Abwandlung, sondern es handelt sich um eine schlichte Kopie. Ja, 1 zu 1. Also es funktionierten sogar die Bugs.
Weiterweg ging auch eine schöne Geschichte zu dem eben schon erwähnten 1834, wenn man das Handbuch nochmal vor sich hat. Die erste Seite beginnt also recht stolz und von wegen die neue sowjetische Entwicklung. Ich glaube K10WM86 hieß der Prozessor. Na ja, und wir waren natürlich alle sehr gespannt, mal aufschrauben und gucken, wie denn der Prozessor aussieht. Also wir schrauben das Ding natürlich auf. Was glänzt uns dagegen? Siemens P 8086. Also immerhin interessant, dass die Russen auch zumindest ihre Firmenbezeichnung von Zeitzeit etwas sehr variabel gestalten.
Das Geniale an dem Z 1013 war ja, dass man sich, das war die reine Platine, mit vier kopierten Handbüchern und einem Flachbandkabel, einem Stecker und einer Tastatur, die man sich selbst zusammenlöten konnte. Und dann musste man sich das Basic, wenn ich mich noch genau daran erinnere, irgendwie über eine Kassette hochladen. Also es war kein integrierter Interpreter, sondern das durch noch alles über eine Kassette.
Wo hast du denn den gekauft?
Den habe ich auch wieder im Pionierplatz gekauft. Da haben sie die Dinger dann ausgehauen zum Schluss. Also sie haben mann Schnee gekostet. Und ein Westcomputer konnte man sich in so um die Wendezeit darum nicht leisten. Aber davor habe ich auch mit dem Kc angefangen. Trau mich ja gar nicht zu sagen. Die allererste Anwendung dafür, die ich gesehen habe, war, dass eine Drehmaschine, ein Stück Wachs zu einer Kerze geformt hat.
Stimmt, das war die erste CNC-Demonstration, die ich gesehen habe mit einem Kc. Stimmt, es war eine interessante Geschichte. Naja, also diese Kopiergeschichte, die Björn da erzählte, dass da viele Sachen einfach nur kopiert wurden. Dieser K 1810 WM 86, also dieser russische Nachbau des Intel 8086, der hatte tatsächlich so viele Wärmeprobleme, dass sie irgendwie dann tatsächlich dazu überwunden sind, in größere Stückzahlen halt irgendwie aus dem Westen Chips einzulöten, die sich ungefähr waggonweise besorgt haben. Woher halt?
Was ich noch sagen wollte ist, ich glaube es war nicht so das Problem, dass der Zoll die Technik nicht eingeführt hat in der DDR, sondern vielmehr die Tatsache, dass man aus dem Westen ja auch nicht einführen durfte. Dass es da auch so eine gewisse Handelsbeschränkung gab.
Es gab die Krokon-Geschichten, die richteten sich allerdings, meines Wissens, ab einem bestimmten Punkt nur noch gegen 16-Bit- und Aufwärtscomputer. Also die 8-Bit-Homecomputer waren davon weitestgehend ausgenommen.
Ja, aber ich habe ein 16-Bit-Computer, 88 bereits gesehen, auf dem Windows oder GM gelaufen ist.
Ja, GM lief da drauf, ne?
War das im Haus der Elektroindustrie, also bei meiner Mutter auf der Arbeit, der Chef, durfte da halt eben dran. Das musste immer sich eingetragen werden. Aber es gab ja auch noch einen anderen Nachbau, einen russischen, irgendwie von der IBM, große Workstation, 70er Jahre muss das gewesen sein. Weil es auch leider nicht mehr wieder hieß. Von der 360er IBM Familie.
Da haben sie wohl auch irgendwas nachgebaut.
Ja, das war der ESA 1022. Das war der IBM 360, Nachbar der Russischen. Der war dann relativ weit verbreitet. Der war ja auch Balkon-kompatibel. Da wurde sozusagen die DDR-Wirtschaft mitbetrieben, mit diesen Maschinen über die langen Jahrzehnte.
So, ich hab inzwischen die Mailbox-Nummer und was ich gehofft hab, Lutz Schramm hört auch zu. Hallo, Lutz. Und hat das bestätigt. Also dieser KC-Emulator liegt auf der Fritz-Mailbox. Denn es gibt nicht nur Fritz-Webpages, sondern es gab vorher auch schon lange eine Mailbox. Das ist also auch so ein bisschen oldschool. Da könnt ihr euch einwählen. Ich erklär das mal jetzt nicht. Also hat nichts zu tun mit der Online. Sondern man muss sich mit einem Terminal-Emulator einwählen mit den üblichen Einstellungen. 8N1 unter der Nummer 0331 für Potsdam. 7213941. Und da findet man auch seinen Weg zum KC-Emulator und kann sich den da downloaden. Ansonsten werden wir auf den Chaos-Seiten dann irgendwo einen Link hinmachen, wo man dieses Zeug im Internet findet. So, machen wir ihn jetzt hier. Das war gerade Robert. Jetzt machen wir Walter.
Wie wärs denn, wenn ihr mal KC-Programme sendet?
Wir hätten es beinahe getan. Ich hab noch zu Hause eine Schaltplatte von Horst Völz, der sich in der DDR sehr verdient gemacht hat um die Entwicklung dieser Kleinkomputerszene. Und der auf diesem Sender, als er noch DT64 hieß, 1989 oder schon 1988, eine Computersendung gemacht hat, wo er tatsächlich KC-Programme im Radio gesendet hat. Und er hat tatsächlich dann auch angefangen, seinen Büchern so eine Flexi-Schaltplatten beizulegen, wo halt auch Programme drauf waren. Das war sozusagen das erste Massendistributionsmedium für solche Programme. Flexi-Disc? Ja, so eine Flexi-Schaltplatte. Diese Werbeschaltplatten, die wir manchmal so kriegten, da hat er halt Programme draufgepresst. Er hat dabei das Buch gepackt, so wie heute eine CD-ROM dabei ist. Weil Diskette gab es halt nicht wirklich so. Super. Und Kassette war halt zu sperrig. Also war wirklich eine geniale Idee. Und der hat das halt richtig lange gemacht. Und eigentlich wollten wir heute auch tatsächlich ein KC-Programm senden. Bloß dummerweise habe ich irgendwie diese Schaltplatte nicht mehr gefunden.
Wie lange, wie groß waren denn die Programme, mit anderen Worten, wie lange hätten wir das spielen müssen?
Einige Minuten.
Super, dann hätten wir hier, also das kennen natürlich auch Vestler von den Kassetten damals, sondern hätten wir jetzt hier ein paar Minuten lang ge-ge-ge-gehört. Das wäre auch toll. Das gibt ja Sendungen auf Ritz, die klingen auch nicht anders. Insofern hätte man vielleicht einfach nur pff pff pff drunter machen müssen und dann sagen...
Liegt auch drunter.
Ach, liegt drunter. Dann hätten wir auch sagen können, das ist die neue Show von DJ Popo oder so.
Ja, man kann auch Kanal-Trennung machen, linken Kanal, irgendein...
Wir hätten geredet auf dem linken Kanal und rechts hätten wir Programme abgespielt. Schade eigentlich, dass du das vergessen hast. Fangen wir an der nächsten Sendung dann zusätzlich. Es gibt übrigens eine E-Mail... Achso, Entschuldigung, weiter, ich hab dich unterbrochen. Jedenfalls ein guter Vorschlag, den wir fast auch gemacht hätten. Knapp daneben ist auch vorbei. Hättest du denn sowas mitgeschnitten?
Naja, ich hab Kc 85, das hatten wir zum ersten Mal gehabt, da war ich sechs Jahre alt, da hatten sich meine Eltern Kc 87 gekauft gehabt. Naja, da lief dann, da ging es irgendwie nur anderthalb Jahre lang, dann hatte er da wohl einen Hardware-Fehler. So sonderlich stabil war die Sache dann offenlich, und dann haben wir uns einen Commodore Plexi gekauft.
Vernünftige Entscheidung.
Aus welcher Quelle?
Weiß ich nicht so genau, wahrscheinlich eine Anzeige irgendwo. Ich weiß nicht, von 4000 Mark hat das Teil gekostet.
Naja, also der graue Markt war doch irgendwie erheblich teuer.
Wer hat sich denn da eigentlich eine goldene Nase dran verdient?
Naja, da gab es so verschiedene Geschichten. Also einerseits gab es so private Schieber, die halt irgendwie die Sachen von den Omis hermüberschmuggeln lassen. Und die haben das halt meistens eine Weile gemacht, bis halt irgendwie die Stasi sie irgendwie am Hintern hatte. Und dann gab es halt zwei Varianten. Entweder die sind halt wegen Gewiesenvergehen im Knast gelandet oder sie haben halt weiter gemacht und haben halt erzählt, was sie so tun, irgendwie bei ihrem Führungsoffizier. Und dann gab es da wieder andere, die halt ihrem Führungsoffizier dann halt nicht alles erzählt haben und die sind dann halt wieder im Knast gelandet. Also da gab es schon solche Geschichten. Es gab halt so offizielle Importlinien, die halt für die Betriebe galten, wo halt die Großrechner importiert wurden und teilweise auch Homecomputer, also für Schreibarbeiten importiert wurden. Die liefen halt auch über das MFS, also diese Beschaffungsabteilung Schaltkolekowski und Co.
Also sehr viele von den größeren Computern, wie zum Beispiel Atari, kamen auch über die Musiker mit ins Land, die halt Pässe hatten, investen fahren durften und sich damit halt auch ein gutes Simchen verdient haben, indem sie halt zum Beispiel die Ataris, die halt für die Tonstudios ziemlich oft eingesetzt wurden, mitgebracht haben.
Weiter, erstmal danke.
Ach, Moment mal, ich hab hier gerade eine Ersatzdroge gefunden.
C plus 4 Programm, ich hab hier gerade die Datasette.
Nein, Verschore.
Du kannst das ja mal kurz einspielen, damit wir einen Eindruck haben, wie so was klingt. Auch noch über Telefon.
Was kenne ich, das ist, also jetzt ist schon bei bestens vier Hörer in die Box geplant.
Wir haben auch das Programm sofort erkannt.
Das Problem ist halt, irgendwie bei diesem C plus 4 war die Übertragungsgeschwindigkeit auf den Kassetten schon dramatisch hoch. Also gegenüber dem Kc war die bestimmt vier oder fünfmal schneller. Also da gab es dann immer diese sogenannten Turbolader, mit denen man die Programme halt irgendwie schneller auf die Kassette spreichern konnte. Bis dann.
Ich habe hier eine E-Mail, die eigentlich sich wieder auf den Kc-Emulator bezieht. Von A.Krappenthin. Hörer eure Sendung, blablabla. Gibt es da eine Möglichkeit, wie man die ganzen schönen Programme vom Kc 85 II auf die PC-Festplatte banden kann? Wie gesagt, da würde ich den Emulator empfehlen. Und dann gibt es ja die Software dann auch auf den PC laden.
Da hat man so, da drauf.
Zwar nicht direkt dann für den Kc, aber immerhin für den Emulator. Vielleicht hilft dir das weiter. Und da, wie gesagt, die entsprechenden Links im Internet dann in den nächsten Tagen auf den Chaos-Seiten, die sind bei www.ccc.de. Schrägstrich Chaosradio, ne? Gut, dann erstmal Musik machen. Supi, das hab ich noch aufliegen.
Vision, die Vision.
Das werden wir. Ach, das ist ja ein schöner Cover, wo man die Titel nicht sieht. Er hört Chaosradio, den Chaos Computer Blumen, den Chaos Computer Blumen bei Fritz. Wir reden über Osttechnologien und werden jetzt noch mit zwei Leuten telefonieren zu Computern, mit Jens und Thorsten nämlich. Und dann werden wir uns mal anderen Technologien zuwenden. Da ist dann gleich Kai dran. Dann gehen wir nämlich mal zum Osttelefon über und wir haben auch noch ein paar andere lecker Bissen für euch. Aber erst mal Jens.
Hi, grüß dich.
Du hast auch noch was zum Kc zu sagen.
Und zwar diesen Emulator, der ist mir also vor vier Wochen in die Hände gefallen im Internet. Und wir bieten das Ding, wir jetzt passen zur Sendung auf unseren Mailboxen an. Ah ja, dann soll es uns da ungelohnt werden. Wir haben drei Lines auf der Kalypso 2 geschaltet.
Wer ist denn wir?
Also das ist ein Betreiberteam, das geht schon zurück bis auf 91.
Namen?
Ja, ist zum Beispiel Mike.
Ich meine jetzt, wie nennt ihr euch als Mailbox? Ah so, Kalypso, alles klar.
Kalypso beziehungsweise KaliNet.
Das kann dann also auch von Brandbohrern über unsere Feilsuche abgefordert werden.
Super, dann sagst du mal die Nummern an.
Jo, das ist die. 935.
Alles in Berlin?
5.4, ja, alles in Berlin.
6.3.
Dann für ihr ist die in die Null. Hinten? Ja, für 28.8, V 34, wäre das die Eins. Und für unsere Zyckl-Freunde haben wir dann noch die zwei hinten dran. Genau, ist dann zu finden Login Kc. Und Passwort auch Kc 85.
Kc 85.
Wird in etwa eine halbe Stunde verfügbar sein.
Super.
Das ist das komplette Paket mit Spielen und dem Emulator.
Na klasse, das ist doch Service. Ich sag die Nummer nochmal durch und sag sie dann auch noch einmal an. 935-5463. Und dann die 0 für ESDN, die 1 für 288 und die 2 für Zyckl. Gut.
Ansonsten hatte ich damals mit dem 85.3 erst einmal Kontakt gehabt. Ich weiss nicht, ob diese Ausstellung noch was gesagt hat. 87 war die.
Wissenschaft und Produktion.
Ja, Berlin in der Seelenbinde. Da hat es im Grunde bei mir angefangen. Und wir haben dann eine kleine Hobby-Programmierer-Truppe sogar eine Zeit lang gehabt. Es fing also so 88 an und ging so bis 90. Falls irgendwann noch mal Programme mit FHC auftauchen sollten, die sind von uns. Aber wie gesagt, die existiert leider nicht mehr. Vielleicht noch mal einen schönen Gruß an die entsprechenden Leute. Und zwar, falls du zuhörst, Bernd in Königswusterhausen. Einer unserer Programmierer oder Kai Uwe in Marzahn.
Das waren sie schon beide? Ja, genau.
Das war also die Truppe, mit der wir damals gearbeitet haben.
Jens, dann vielen Dank erstmal. Ich sag die Nummern nachher noch mal durch, damit sich alle bei euch einloggen können. Username ist Kc und Passwort ist Kc 85.
Genau, und wenn noch Fragen sind oder jemand die Nummer nicht mitkriegt, wir haben auch eine Webpage, die wäre dann unter www.obdg.de Warte mal, obdg.
Carlinet Mit Y Für Calypso Carlinet Alles klar Vielen Dank Bis denn Nach dem nächsten Fritz-Kurz-Info nochmal alles durch, wo man den Kc-Emulator bekommt. Damit hätten wir das jetzt erst mal so weit abgeschlossen. Reden jetzt mit Thorsten einen Computer, über den wir noch nicht geredet haben. Thorsten ist weg, dann müsst ihr was sagen. Thorsten steht hier, hat angefangen mit dem R 300 bis hin zum P 8000. Neue Buchstaben, neue Zahlen, neues Glück.
Ja, wäre schön, wenn Thorsten nochmal anrufen könnte, weil diesen R 300, den habe ich persönlich glaube ich nur einmal gesehen. Da war ich im Reichsbahn-Ausbesserungswerk oder so und habe da meine Sommerpraktik gemacht und da stand auf dem Flur so eine große lange Reihe von so Stahlschränken, so ungefähr so 1, 80 m hoch und fast genauso breit und die waren so mit unglaublich vielen kleinen Leiterplatten vollgestopft. Das war halt ein R 300. Und das Modem alleine hatte ungefähr, also für die Verbindung über Telefonleiter, hatte die große eines Kachelofens, ungelogen. Und machte wohl glaube ich 300 Baut oder so. Also das war wirklich eine brutale Maschine. Die stande so von Anfang der 70er Jahre und wenn Thorsten noch ein bisschen mehr erzählen könnte, wäre es irgendwie toll. Der P8000 war so eine der letzten Entwicklungen in der DDR. Es war eine Unix-Maschine, die auf dem Z8000 aufsetzte, also dem Nachfolger des Z80 Prozesses von Cylog. Und da gab es halt auch Varianten.
Zwei Varianten, sogenannte Gruppé-Varianten, die eben diese 16-Bit- und als Unix-Betriebssystem Grundname Vega hatte. Unix System 3, wenn ich mich nicht irre.
Version 7 meiner Meinung nach. Also noch Force System 3.
Wirklicherweise je nach Monat.
Auseinander, nicht schleiten.
Dann war es vor allem die schicken Terminals, wo Robotron draufsteht, das ist das einzige, was man heutzutage noch verwenden kann. Echt VT-100-kompatibel, kann man auch noch durchaus an ein modernes Unix-System anschließen. Und hat aber trotzdem noch das schöne alte Feeling und die alten Tasten und den schönen alten Grünmultor.
Da spricht der Sammler.
So, jetzt haben wir auch Thorsten nochmal. Und der klebt dann auch nochmal zur R 300. Dann ist erstmal Schluss mit Computern, wir haben noch andere Sachen. Thorsten, hallo.
Ja, hallo, hier ist der Thorsten.
So, verloren und wiedergefunden.
Ja, genau, hat ein bisschen lange gedauert. Ich habe 1986 angefangen mit dem Studium und Elektronik. Und nach meinem Studium musste ich den R 300 reparieren. Also ihr werdet es nicht glauben. 89, dann die Dinger noch in der DDR.
Wo denn?
Bei der Firma Bergmann-Borsig ehemals. Die hatten das Ding noch zur Lohnabrechnung. Das füllte drei Räume, hatte einen Ferritkernspeicher und die haben das Ding in drei Schichten betrieben.
Cool, in der Wartung oder wie?
Ich hab Wartung gemacht, ja. Da war auch immer ein Wartungsingenieur, der da ständig mit dem Lötkorn rum gerannt ist und hat dort noch alte Technik denn gelötet.
Sag mal, dann sag doch mal so ein paar Vergleichsweisezahlen, was jetzt so junge Computerbenutzer, die kennen ja irgendwie so die Geschwindigkeiten ihrer Rechner und was da so an Speicher vorhanden ist und so weiter. Dann sag doch mal für diese Riesenkiste, wo man also wahrscheinlich so Computer, wie man sie aus alten Science-Fiction Serien kennt, Riesenschränke, du hast gesagt, drei Räume wurden damit belegt. Gibt es da so ein paar Zahlen vergleichsweise? Was haben diese Riesenkisten bewegt und was hatten die für Daten?
Ja, also wie gesagt, für Riedkernspeicher, der hatte glaube ich 256K und füllte einen Schrank, also wirklich einen Schrank. Und man muss dazu sagen, wenn man den eingeschaltet hat, musste man das Ding erst vorheizen. Also der brauchte eine konstante Temperatur. Also der musste auf 55 Grad innen gefahren werden, damit der Speicher überhaupt erst mal funktionierte. Also eine Stunde Heizen war da angesagt. Wir haben zum Beispiel ein Problem gehabt, dass wir Montagmorgen diese Maschine wieder anfahren mussten und wir haben erst mal einen halben Tag gelötet.
Echt, bis 89 haben die das betrieben?
89, ja, wurde da immer noch mit dran gebaut und dran rumgefahren. Also das ist mit Lochkarte gewesen, Eingabegerät war eine Schreppmaschine und Ausgabegerät war gleichzeitig auch die Schreppmaschine. Das war so, wie man vielleicht in alten Filmen noch sieht, dass da irgendwie so ein Tacker hin und her läuft, also ohne Monitor.
War echt heiße Sache.
89, ja wie gesagt, also vom Studium her kannte ich die P 8000, war recht gut damals schon und dann wie gesagt auf in den R 300. Also ich war ganz froh, dass es denn vorbei war.
Sag mal früher, bei uns im Westen hieß es ja EDV, alles was mit Computern zu tun hat, elektronische Datenverarbeitung. Was habt ihr gesagt?
Wir haben genauso EDV gesagt.
Auch EDV.
War auch EDV.
Und gibt es irgendwas, bist du jetzt immer noch mit Computern beschäftigt?
Ich bin immer noch mit Computern beschäftigt.
Gibt es da irgendwas aus dem ganzen Wissen, was du ja da definitiv haben musstest? Gibt es da irgendwas, was du mit rüber retten konntest sozusagen, was dir heute noch was nützt, wo du ein bisschen nasenlänge voraus bist?
Na voraus denke ich nicht, aber wir hatten relativ viel Grundlagen. Ich habe zum Beispiel während meines Studiums aus dem Funkamateur, den PC gebaut. Und ich muss sagen, dahingehend ist einem relativ viel wahrscheinlich von der Pieke auf bekannt. Also wenn man so ein Ding mal selbst zusammen gelötet hat. Also was macht die Pieke oder diese oder jene, das ist dann auf jeden Fall so ein Selbstlöter bestimmt weitaus besser bekannt, als jemand, der sich das Ding im Laden kauft. Ich habe bestimmt, naja, sagen wir mal, einen Monat die Tastatur gebaut, aus irgendwelchen Scheitern zusammen. Unglaublich. Und ja, das Ding steht bei mir noch auf dem Boden. Ich hoffe, dass ich ihn irgendwann noch mal aktivieren kann. Denn gab es im Osten bis ich so einen kleinen Junos. Den brauchte man dann unbedingt. Das war so ein komischer russischer Fernseher. Und so ein Virao oder wie das Ding hieß, so ein Kassettenrekorder, wo eigentlich nur eine Abspätkaste dran war. Das musste man sich dann alles besorgen. Das war dann irgendwie auch ein Computer.
Na ja, also die Nachbauanleitungen waren ja in ziemlich vielen Zeitungen drin. Also so ein Approch-All-Elektronik-Zeitung bis hin zum Schluss zu so einer Jugend und Technik, also so einer populärwissenschaftlichen Jugendzeitung. Die hatten dann alle Nachbauanleitungen für Computer. Und immer, wenn irgendwie eine von diesen Nachbauanleitungen erschienen, wurden dann in Bastelläden bestimmte Schaltkreise knapp, weil die dann gerade verwendet wurden. Und na ja, also diese Nachbau-Computer, die findet man öfter noch so bei irgendwie alt eingesessenen DDR-Funkamateurn und sonstigen Elektronikbastlern. Die haben meistens noch irgendwie so ein Ding irgendwo rumstehen und trennen sich natürlich auch nicht davon, weil sie halt viele Monate Schweiß, Mühe, Beschaffung und Löten investiert haben, um sich da ihren Computer zusammenzulöten.
Na, wie gesagt, ich hab ihn ja auch noch.
In AC1 oder was?
Na genau, den 1000 Funkamateur. Ja, ich hatte nun vielleicht in der Hinsicht Glück, beim Studium Elektronik trafen sich ja nun alle auf den Elektronikbuden der DDR. Und da konnte jeder irgendwo noch andere Teile hochziehen, die es eigentlich nicht gab. Da brachte jeder ein bisschen mit. Und da wurden dann drei, vier solche Dinger dann zusammengelötet.
Draußen nicht wegschmeißen.
Nee, nee, habe ich noch. Und wie gesagt, vielleicht noch eine kleine Geschichte zum Kc 85. Kc 85 hieß der, glaube ich. Also ich habe in Girls studiert und die Dinger standen dort in dem sogenannten Computerkabinett. Also sprich, Hightech wurde am Kc 85 vermittelt. Zehn Stück nebeneinander und da haben wir dann so die ersten Programmierschritte dran unternehmen sollen.
Ja, war ein bisschen andere Zeiten noch sowieso. Stimmt und 89 hast du noch mit der R 300. Thorsten, ich dank dir. Bis denn. Ja, da kommen ja doch nette Anekdoten aus. PC selber basteln, monatelange Arbeit. Mir hat es ja schon gereicht, wenn man irgendwelche Programme abgetippt hat. Das fand ich schon anstrengend. Besonders wenn dann die Federsuche einen Monat dauerte und dann konnten wir lesen, wir hatten leider einen Druckfehler.
Da waren Rom-Listings in den Zeitungen drin, so irgendwie 8 Seiten, 4 so mit Hexzahl, irgendwie quer, irgendwie 4-spaltig und die musstest du dann abtippen und da war dann halt der Urloder für deinen Computer drin.
Dann einmal 2B statt 2C getippt und schade.
Dann mutete das Ding halt nicht so.
Wir hatten ja viel Zeit, da meint ihr also noch. Deadlift auch noch mal kurz zum R300.
Ja, also ich hab ja am R300 selber gearbeitet als Delina und dann später noch so ein bisschen in der Wartung mitgeholfen. In Cottbus, wir hatten ja damals auch ein großes Rechenzentrum. Und die hatten auch, also ich war in Cottbus bis 80 und da stand also noch der A300. Und wir haben rund um die Uhr auch gearbeitet dort. Und von der Kapazität her, also der Fritkan-Speicher selber, der hätte also nie ausgereicht, um überhaupt ein Programm offen zu lassen. Da gab es dann Magnetband-Speicher, das waren so eine 12-Toll-Bänder, Schranke 2 Meter und die Breite etwa einen Meter, für ein Bandgerät.
Die kann man auch noch ausfüllen, diese Bandzinsspeicher.
Ja, die Pufferhebel, um dann die Bänder abzupuffern, damit sie nicht verreißen, wenn sie jetzt die entsprechenden Stellen suchen mussten, nicht? Da hatten wir Trommelspeicher drinne, wie nannten die?
Blasenspeicher?
Das war praktisch, wie wir sagen, wie ein Zylinder aufgebohrt. Und ein Speicher hatte 40K. Also eine Vollausstattung waren dann vier Trommeln. Das war dann das absolut Maximale am A300.
Und das wurde darauf gemacht, dass so Lohnbuchhalte waren?
Ja, da konnte man Daten ablegen, richtig. Also die Leute in einer Festplatte waren.
Ich meine, was mit dem Rechner gemacht wurde.
Lohnbuchhaltung, dann war hier optimierisch beide Kartoffeln, hier die Geschichten, nicht? OGS ist ständig gefahren. Die großen Schullehnen hier, HO und Konsum und solche Geschichten. Also Dienstleistung, nein.
Und machst du heute immer noch einen Computer?
Ich mache heute immer noch, ja.
Was machst du heute?
Hauptsächlich Dienstleistung, ja. Also ich bin selbstständig.
Und hast du noch mit anderen Rechnern zu tun gehabt im Osten?
Also ich habe hier noch zu stehen, der LC 80, der ist vielleicht unausbekannt. Denn den NC 80, das war dieser, wo man den E-Pomps programmieren konnte, solche Geschichten.
Das war ein PC mit eingebauten E-Prombrenner, der war standardmäßig da drin.
Dann habe ich hier zu stehen ein Kc 85 IV, der hat praktisch einen Floppy Drive und einen Floppy Controller. Läuft auch noch, den hatten die Kinder eine ganze Weile. Und dann in eine Sammlung mit drin ist reingekommen, der erste tragbare C64, das war der.
Den kenne ich auch noch.
Das ist ein schweres Teil übrigens.
Das ist so, wo man vorne das Keyboard runterklappt, dann hat man so einen super kleinen Monitor. Ja, sehr schick eigentlich. War super teuer, oder?
Na, ich habe den beide technisch verstanden. Also war ich.
Hast du denn eine richtig elaborierte Sammlung da?
Dann so ein tragbaren, ich sag mal, der erste tragbare von die Schneider hier.
Welche Sachen.
Ja, wir kommen gleich mal alle vorbei. Bis denn, ciao. Also gibt es doch mehrere Leute, die da sammeln, richtig. Ich würde nachher gerne noch mal hören, was die Unterschiede sind.
Zum einen zum Thema Sammeln. In der Seabase stehen auch noch einige ältere Computer, unter anderem der Ec 10 22 und Kc 85 2 steht da glaube ich auch noch und noch das eine oder andere Modell.
Die Seabase ist an der Uranienburger Straße 3?
Zwei? Zwei.
Ja, wenn nicht www.seabase.org. Genau, da müssen wir mal aufpassen mit den Endungen. So, jetzt wechseln wir ein bisschen die Richtung. Es geht nicht mehr wirklich um Computer, sondern mit Kai bist du noch da? Super. Sondern um Osttelefonie.
Ich weiß noch, ich bin zwar jetzt 17, also ich hab das nicht mehr ganz so genau mitgekriegt, aber damals zu 1989, da hatten wir noch hier so ein Telefon mit W-Scheibe, das ist ja jetzt überhaupt nicht mehr.
Das hatten wir im Westen auch.
Jaja, aber wir haben mir dann hier auch immer in den Leitungen die ganzen Gespräche schön mithören können.
Achso, wie, was waren das für Gespräche bei euch im Haus?
Nee, nee, richtig, wenn ich jetzt einen Hörer abgenommen hab, ging es wirklich manchmal, ja, der Inhalt gerade irgendwo angerufen ist, nur wirklich passiert, dass ich da gehört hab, wie sich zwei unterhalten haben, ja, wie geht's dir denn im Krankenhaus? Ach, ganz gut und so, es ist wirklich passiert.
Ja, die Qualität des DDR-Telefonnetzes war teilweise besorgnisierend.
Ja, ich kann mich auch erinnern, dass monatelang Fehler existiert, wenn man bestimmte Ziffern gewählt hat, drei, vier Ziffern, dann kann man jedes Mal auf ein Gespräch drauf.
Also das Telefonnetz in der DDR war halt komplett analog, also da gab es halt keine digitalen Vermittlungsstellen. Ja, genau, vor allem mechanisch mit Hebtdrehwählern. Und zusätzlich dazu gab es halt noch diverse Telefonnetze von allen möglichen Behörden. Zum Beispiel gab es auch ein Telefonnetz der Zuckerindustrie, die dann sozusagen ihre, heute würde man sagen, Corporate Networks hatten, wieder auch mit mechanischen Hebtdrehwählern. Und naja, die Geschichten mit den Zweieranschlüssen, die haben uns ja noch bis in die jüngste Zukunft begleitet.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch jeder kennt. Also es gab in der DDR halt das Problem der knappen Telefonanschlüsse. Das wurde gelöst durch die sogenannten Gum-Anschlüsse. Gum-Gemeinschaftsumschalter heißt, auf einer Leitung hingen zwei Leute, zwei getrennte Wohneinheiten. Und realisiert wurde das Ganze durch diese Platine-Gemeinschaftsumschalter. Wenn einer gesprochen hat oder einer angerufen wurde, und gerade die telefonierte, war der Anschluss des anderen Gesprächspartners tot. Und nun fühlt ihr das manchmal zu ärgerlichen Szenen. Da es halt Leute gab, die auch schon zu DDR-Zeiten mehr als andere telefonierten, muss zum Beispiel mein Nachbar damals ziemlich gelitten haben. Jedenfalls, wenn er mal des Öfteren telefonierte und ich musste halt dringend ein Gespräch führen, wurde das dadurch realisiert, dass er halt über seinen Gemeinschaftsumschalter aus der Leitung geworfen wurde, indem man ihn einfach kurzschloss, ihn sozusagen aus dem Gespräch katapultierte und dann selber telefonieren konnte. Das hat dann natürlich über die Zeit irgendwie Fehlermeldungen an die Post rausgegeben, die sich die ganze Sache dann genauer angeguckt hat. Und bis dahin sollte man halt dann die Umschalteinrichtung wieder in den Originalzustand zurückversetzt haben. Ansonsten gab es ziemliche Ärger. Bei mir ist keiner aufgetaucht, aber ich kenne jemand, bei dem halt jemand aufgetaucht ist von der Post und sich die ganze Sache etwas genauer angeguckt hat, da halt den kleinen Scheiter zum Rausschmeißen der anderen Partei gefunden hat.
Dann haben sie keinen Telefonanschluss mehr gehabt?
Doch, aber es gab eine deutliche Warnung. Und zweitens gab es noch die sogenannten Kombinatsanschlüsse. Das war eine Art Gemeinschaftsanschluss, nicht mit einer Privatperson, sondern mit einem Kombinat oder mit einem volkseignen Betrieb, wo quasi an der gleichen Leitung tagsüber der volkseigene Betrieb mit seinen vielleicht 300 Nebenstellen hing. Und auf der anderen Seite hing man halt selber dran. Und da man sich ja überlegen kann, wie viele Telefonate in etwa bei 300 Nebenstellen rausgehen, kann man sich die Chancen auch ausrechnen, die der Privatanschluss dann hatte, zu telefonieren.
Kai, weißt du zumindest ein bisschen, woran es gelegen hat, dass du Gespräche mithören konntest? Kai, ich sag dir schon mal Tschüss, ja? Danke dir. Dir auch. Wenn ich jetzt die Regler hochziehe, kriegen wir vielleicht ein Gespräch mit. Mal gucken. Auch davor ist man ja nicht ganz gefallen. Ich habe ein E-Mail, das ich kurz vorlesen möchte. Erstens hat Lutz ganz schnell reagiert. Lutz schramm schreibt, was die können kann ich auch. Adresse ist www.fritz.de slash kc. Da liegt jetzt der Kc-Emulator für alle, die in den Internetzugang kamen und nur für dieses Jahr so interessant. Die können sich da jetzt den Kc-Emulator und wahrscheinlich dann auch entsprechend andere Sachen runterladen. www.fritz.de slash kc. Ganz einfach zu merken also. Das soweit Lutz.
Vielen Dank Lutz.
Er sitzt zu Hause und fiebert mit. Das finde ich schön. Hier ist was völlig anderes. Gibt es noch was zur Sperrung von www.accessforall.de in Niederlande zu hören, ist nicht Thema. Stimmt, ist aber wichtig. Es stimmt auch. Gibt es aber heute nichts zuzuhören, oder? Also ich glaube so diese Geschichten wie in Österreich und so, da müssen wir nochmal eine Sendung drüber machen.
Habt ihr da was nicht da?
Ach, da habt ihr ja so darüber geredet.
Ah, schön.
Ich fasse ja nur auf, dass wenn ich nicht da bin, dass ich auch schöne Sachen mache. Hier kommt auch noch was völlig anderes. Ich glaube, das solltet ihr so beantworten, dass es nicht in die Sendung passt. Und jetzt hätte mal eine kleine Frage. Mir hat jemand hoch und heilig versichert, dass der erste 386er in der DDR produziert wurde. Ich glaube das zwar nicht, aber vielleicht wisst ihr es ja besser. Kommt von Marco.
Es gab in meiner Schleusenzeit in der DDR keinen.
Auf überhaupt gar keinen Fall.
Es gab glaube ich einige wenige Handmuster von 286ern, aber es gab auf gar keinen Fall einen 386er. Es gab halt irgendwie diverse 32-Bit-Rechner, die heute alle Schlafzimmer größer hatten, aber es gab halt keinen regulären 386er.
Vielleicht hatte das von der Mittelseile des Eulenspiegels. Da kommt immer die Ausgabe, was wäre, wenn es anders gekommen wäre. 5-7 Jahre nach dem Anschluss der Bundesrepublik an die DDR. Wernem, Vib, BMW. Jetzt statt dekadenten Luxus-Karossen-Blumentöpfe-Produktion oder ähnliches. Aber aus der Rubrik kommt das raus.
Gleich gibt es einen Fritz-Kurz-Info. Dann geht's weiter mit Osttechnologie im Chaosradio. Es ist 23.30 Uhr.
Aktion, eine Gruppe armenischer Kurden hat heute das Gelände der USA-Botschaft in Bonn besetzt. Sie wollte damit ihre für heute geplante Abschiebung aus Deutschland verhindern. Die etwa 20 Kurden verließen am Abend freiwillig das Gelände. Luftbrücke, die UNO, hat die ersten ruandischen Flüchtlinge aus Ost-Zaire ausgeflogen, darunter viele weisen Kinder. Insgesamt sollen fast 100.000 Menschen wieder in ihre Heimat gebracht werden. Notbremse in der Stadt Brandenburg ist eine Haushaltssperre verhängt worden. Ausgenommen sind notwendige Ausgaben wie zum Beispiel Sozialhilfe, aber auch die Gelder für die Kinder- und Jugendarbeit. Urteil, die rechtsextreme NPD darf morgen am 1. Mai in Leipzig nicht demonstrieren. Dies entschied am Abend in letzter Instanz das sächsische Oberverwaltungsgericht. Dennoch werden Auseinandersetzungen befürchtet. Mayday in der Dortmunder Westfalenhalle begann am Abend das alljährliche Techno-Spektakel. Die Veranstalter erwarten bis zu 20.000 Fans auf der 16-stündigen Dauerfete mit rund 40 Live-Acts und DJs aus Europa, den USA und Japan. Fußball in einem Qualifikationsspiel zur Weltmeisterschaft 1998 gewann Deutschland gegen die Ukraine mit 2 zu 0. Heute Nacht kaum noch Regen bei 9 bis 5 Grad, morgen zunächst stark bewirkt, später teils heiter, Temperaturen um 15 bis 18 Grad. Da gibt es keine aktuellen Meldungen mehr.
Von Gerald Kütterheimreich, der auch das Fritz-Kurzinfo verlaß.
The Crazy World der Fritz präsentiert Sonic Empire Die 12.
Ich glaube, die Hits kenne ich alle tatsächlich. Ihr hört Chaosradio mit vielen Ostmusik, denn wir reden über Osttechnologie, der Chaos Computer Club Blumenau hier bei Fritz. Jetzt gibt es noch mal zusammengefasst die Infos für den KC Emulator, ein alter Ostcomputer, den man jetzt auf dem PC benutzen kann mittels eines Emulators. Und da gibt es auch die entsprechende Software dazu. Einmal könnt ihr ihn in der Fritz Mailbox runterladen. Die Fritz Mailbox Nummer ist 0331. 7213941. Weitere Mailbox-Nummern kommen von Calypso. Das dürfte jetzt auch langsam online sein. Da ist die Nummer in Berlin 9355463. Und dann gibt es verschiedene Endnummern, nämlich die 0 für ISDN, die 1 für 288 und die 2 für, Zitat, unsere Zyxl-Freunde. Username ist Kc und Passwort ist Kc 85. Mehr Info über die Kalypso Mailbox, wir machen gerne Werbung hier im Internet unter www.obdg.de-kalinet mit Y. Außerdem für Internet-User der Kc-Emulator bei Fritz, www.fritz.de-kc, glaube ich die einfachste Adresse. Jetzt kommt hier von Thomas eine Anfrage zu diesem Kc-Emulator. Der hat den nämlich und fragt, wer ihn langsamer machen kann.
Du musst die Turbotaste rausnehmen, es hilft alles nichts.
Hier steht es, die sind einfach zu schnell.
Die Zeit läuft zu schnell ab. Bei dem Kc-64-Emulator gibt es auch eine Limit-Speed.
Ich denke mal, dann würde er nicht fragen. Er sagt jetzt noch in der zweiten Mail, wenn es keine fertige Software gibt, so würde ich noch gerne wissen, ob es etwas bringen würde, einfach in einen der Timer interrupts eine kleine Routine einzubinden, die eben ein wenig Prozessorzeit beansprucht.
Probier es doch aus.
Das gibt es im Übrigen auch fertig.
Ansonsten, also ein probates Mittel, den auf langsame Geschwindigkeit zu bringen, ist, sich Software auf dem Mac zu installieren und dann in diesem evolierten PC auf dem Macintosh den KC EVO-Leiter zu starten. Super!
Und wenn das alles nichts hilft, kann man ihn noch sputen und diesen Macintosh wiederum auf dem PC betreiben.
Ja. Ach, was macht ihr beruflich alle?
Wie viel Zeit ihr eure Reise?
Was habt ihr noch für Zeit übrig? Wir sind jetzt aber von den Computern ein bisschen weg, ich glaube über den Kc haben wir jetzt auch viel geredet, sondern wir sind jetzt beim Telefon. Osttelefonie.
Naja, du hast es doch, sich hatte ich noch gemerkt, 1990, 1991 war doch irgendwie noch Osttelefonie in allen ihren Formen und Farben verfügbar.
Ich kenn's auch noch von ganz früher, ich weiß, dass das zum Beispiel für meine Eltern, die hatten Verwandte, mein Vater hatte Verwandte im Osten und es war richtig schwierig da, also abgesehen davon, dass die dann kein Telefon hatten, man musste sich verabreden für einen bestimmten Zeitpunkt, wo die dann wo waren, wo jemand ein Telefon hat und selbst dann war es äußerst schwierig eine Verbindung zu kriegen.
Na ja, es gab halt irgendwie nur einige hundert Leitungen in den Westen und die waren halt natürlich irgendwie alle überwacht, deswegen waren es auch so wenig, damit die Abherlast nicht so hoch stieg und naja, die haben sich dann halt alle gedrängelt da drauf, alle Leute. Und dann nach der Wende hat es natürlich richtig zugeschlagen, da sind dann halt irgendwie alle Leitungen, die es irgendwie gab, geschaltet worden und dann gab es halt Leute, ich kann mich noch erinnern, auf der Karl-Marx-Halle gab es so einen Schuppen, die haben es irgendwie geschafft, sich Westleitungen da hinlegen zu lassen und haben dann da so eine illegale Koppelung zwischen Ostnetz und Westnetz gemacht, so mit so einer Art umgedrehten Akustikkoppler, wo sie dann halt ein Telefonwasser im Westnetz hingen, ein Telefonwasser im Ostnetz hingestöpselt haben und da konnte man dann halt irgendwie garantiert für richtig viel Geld im Monat irgendwie nach dem Westen telefonieren.
Was heißt das C-Netz 1990?
Ja, 1990 war C-Netz irgendwie die wahre Option. Das war halt so ein Schuppen, so ein Laden irgendwie.
Da konntest du hingehen und telefonieren und konntest halbwegs sicher sein, dass du eine Verbindung kriegst.
So in der Richtung, ja. Für viel Geld. Für viel Geld.
Und C-Netz dann die Option, also C-Netz ist analogemobil Funknetz vor den ganzen D-Netzen und so, was A größere Geräte hatte, B ein bisschen teurer war und schlechtere Qualität hatte, wobei auch heute noch Leute darauf schwören.
Naja, es strahlt ja nicht so in den Kopf, weil es keine digitale Modulation hat.
Man konnte übrigens mit C-Netz auch Akustikkopplar betreiben. Ich hab dann mit 300 Bord.
Naja, und nach der Wende war C-Netz so die Option, wenn man halt irgendwie schnell Telefon haben wollte, also noch lange. Ich kam hier dann mein erstes Telefon, mein erstes eigenes Telefon war auch kein Festnetzanschluss, sondern ein C-Netz Telefon, was sich irgendwie, naja, war zu groß und wurde immer freundlichen Bodenstation genannt. Und das hatte ich glaube ich bis 94 oder so, bevor ich ein richtiges Telefon bekommen habe.
Was mich jetzt auch mal interessiert, Chaos Computer Club, zumindest in Berlin, ist jetzt so Ost-West-Verhältnis, wie ist das? Also ihr sitzt im Osten?
Naja, also das Verhältnis des Chaos Computer Clubs in Berlin ist ganz wesentlich von einer anderen Institution, bestimmt nicht vom HDOT Computer Club. Das war einer der vielen Computer Clubs, die es in der DDR gab und der war halt in Berlin, im Haus der jungen Talente. Und zeichnete sich dadurch aus, dass da halt ziemlich viele Leute unterwegs waren, die halt auch Westcomputer hatten. Und da gab es dann halt immer wilde Tausend Parfys. Da war dann, ich glaube, es war mal Donnerstag.
Es war Donnerstag.
Donnerstags, genau.
Da war dann...
Das ist nicht Amelias mit X-Copy und in der Ecke ein einsamer PC.
Und dann wurde da halt irgendwie geschaufelt, was das Zeug hielt. Also der HDOT Computer Club war halt sehr Westcomputer dominiert, da gab es halt kaum, also ich glaube, gar keine Ostcomputer. Und naja, es war halt schon irgendwie eine ziemlich, ziemliches Erlebnis da zum ersten Mal reinzukommen und halt irgendwie einen großen Raum irgendwie voller Leute zu sehen, die halt irgendwie alle über den Rechner gebeugt sind und dann halt irgendwie kopieren, was das Zeug hält.
Wie kamen denn die ersten Kontakte zustande? Und wie waren so die ersten Treffen jetzt? So euer Club und der andere Club?
Na die kamen 1990 zustande, ich weiß gar nicht worüber, über gemeinsame Bekannte halt, die halt irgendwie zum Chaos Club irgendwie Verbindungen hatten. Und naja, und so hat sich die Sache im Jahre 1990 dann halt allmählich entwickelt bis dahin, dass es dann 1990 den CoConn gab, sozusagen den ersten Chaos-Kongress im Osten, halt in diesem HDAT, der halt irgendwie weitestgehend von den Wessigs bestritten wurde, weil wir irgendwie doch noch irgendwie heftig damit zu tun hatten, erst überhaupt mit den Realitäten klarzukommen mit den Neuen. Und naja, und von daher sind dann so, die haben sich die Leute langsam zusammengefunden, die heutzutage den Chaos Computer Club in Berlin bilden.
Wollt ihr mit einem Osttelefonmann telefonieren?
Oh ja, gerne.
Ich war zu Ostzeiten bei der Deutschen Post gewesen, ich war Telefontechniker, hatte auch einen Titel, ich war O-Assistent, ja. Das war so, ich sag mal, dass ich das mal kriegen konnte. Und wenn ihr da euch über PC-Technik aus DDR-Zeiten unterhaltet, die letztendlich jetzt irgendwie schon veraltet dargestellt wurden, dann war das zu den Zeiten, wo ich gegenüber der Post hochmodern gewesen, also in dem Telefonamt, wo ich gearbeitet hatte, da hat man mit Siemens-Halske-Hipptrebeler-Technik von 1928 gearbeitet.
Ja, 1928 schon. Da hatten wir eine Vermittlungsstelle im Raum Leipzig besichtigt, die war von 1923.
Ja, und da sind dann die Techniker abends mit einem Besen langgegangen, um dann die Messingsspäne wieder zusammen zu ziehen. Das war dann der Abtrieb eines Tages gewesen. Im Prinzip haben wir eigentlich alte Techniker gehabt. Es gab dann kurz vor der Wende ein paar Jahre dann so eine halbelektronische Nebenstellenanlage. Die konnte dann eine Amtsleitung und fünf Nebenstellen verwalten, mit Germaniumtechnik noch, wenn das mal jemand was sagt. Also war ein Riesenkasten gewesen, mit Relais aufgebaut. Die vorhergehende Anlage war entschieden kleiner gewesen. Die waren mit Relais. Da hatten wir so ein paar nette Sachen mit erlebt. Wir waren dann auch letztendlich Bock im Service gewesen, in die Betriebe gefahren, haben dann deren Anlagen gewartet.
Sag mal, wenn du Osttelefonmann warst, dann kannst du uns vielleicht hier was bestätigen, was Marco jetzt noch mal geschrieben hat, der sich bedankt für die schnelle 386er-Fragebeantwortung. Der schreibt nämlich, man konnte zu Ostzeiten in den Telefonzellen kostenlos telefonieren, indem man die erste Nummer rückwärts und anschließend richtig rumwählte.
Ich hab's ausprobiert.
Ja, pass auf, und zwar gab's im Prinzip Münchensprecher jetzt noch, sagen wir mal die alten Blechkisten, mit mechanischen Nummernschaltern und auch mechanischer Auswertung. Und zwar, es war so ein Sperrnummernschalter, da konnte man Notrufnummern umsonst telefonieren, 110 und sowas, 112 Polizei. Und das wurde alles mechanisch ausgewertet mit diesen irgendwelchen Relais und Nummernschalter selber, also diese Wählscheibe ist das ja. Und wenn man dann die 11 und noch eine beliebige Zahl gewählt hat und dann langsam die Nummernscheibe wieder zurückgewählt hat, dann ist das eingerastet für im Prinzip umsonst telefonieren und man konnte dann beliebig irgendwohin telefonieren. Das war allerdings meistens nicht für Ferndienste zugelassen, die Münchnernsprecher, also im Ort und so. In näherer Umgebung konnte man damit telefonieren.
Wie wählt man deine Nummer rückwärts? Das verstehe ich jetzt nicht.
Man lässt den Nummernschalter ganz langsam rückwärts laufen. Und dadurch gibt es im Prinzip, ist es so, als wenn man auflegt und wieder abnimmt.
Verstehe.
Im Prinzip beim Drehen wird nichts weiter gemacht, als die Leitung unterbrochen und wiederhergestellt. Man kann auch, wenn man oben auf die Gabel raufdrückt, auch wählen. Wenn man zehnmal in einer Sekunde schnell raufdrückt, hat man die Null gewählt. Neunmal in einer Sekunde hat man die Neun gewählt. Das ist ein ganz einfaches Wahlverfahren letztendlich.
Das ging übrigens heute auch noch. An manchen Taxi-Hubsäulen stehen Telefone ohne Wählscheibe. Und da kann man dann auf die Gabel kloppen.
Das ist das sogenannte IBI-Wahlverfahren.
Ach super, man geht einfach an einen leeren Taxistand und mit dem Hörer dann...
Und Maus legt dann seine Nummer zurecht.
Super, dann nimmt man einfach seinen Laptop mit und geht online.
Nein, aber im Falle geht das vielleicht auch schon mit einem...
Es gab aber auch noch eine andere Möglichkeit, umsonst zu telefonieren, bei Betrieben, die sogenannte Durchwahlapparate hatten, wo man also im Prinzip den letzten Apparat in den Betrieb selber erreichen konnte, ohne handvermittelt zu werden. Da hat man sich dann reingewählt und dann in die Anlage selber und dann aber die Null, um wieder rauszukommen, dass man im Prinzip in den Betrieb rein und über den Betrieb wieder raustelefoniert, ins öffentliche Netz. Und die Kosten gingen dann als Lastnissbetriebe.
Das konnte man besonders gut in Basa machen, das war das Netz von der Reichsbahn. Da konnte man sich sogar in Berlin reinwählen, dann Kodbus wieder raus und von da quer durch die Republik.
Das Basanetz war ja ein völlig separates Netz. Da gab es auch noch das sogenannte R-Netz, das war dann das Regierungsnetz. Die hatten dann auch völlig eigene Leitungen, waren dann im Prinzip Rat des Kreises und so dann untereinander angeschlossen. Da hatte ich auch mal ein bisschen mit zu tun gehabt. Dann gab es dann noch die Stasi-Netz. Da hatten wir auch ein bisschen was mit zu tun gehabt. Wir mussten dann immer letztendlich als Postmuckels dann Leitungen schalten, sogenannte Sonderleitungen, Standleitungen für Staatssicherheit. Das war immer ganz interessant gewesen. Weil letztendlich, wir mussten die Leitungen irgendwie prüfen, aber am anderen Ende die Leute, die haben nicht geantwortet, man hat immer nur schnaufen gehört, man konnte ansprechen, die haben irgendwie Redeverbot gehabt, wenn nicht ein Codewort genannt wurde. Hab es dann auch mal geschafft, so eine Leitung mal abzuhören, dann haben wir dann wirklich irgendein Codewort genannt und dann überhaupt im Prinzip wie ein Zugangscod letztendlich, wenn er nicht genannt wurde, am anderen Ende hat er den völlig ignoriert, hat doch gar nichts gesagt. Es war also schon ziemlich clever aufgebaut. Da gab es sogar in dem Ort eine kostenlose Nummer, wo ich sage mal Staatsbesicherheitsmitarbeiter, die auf der Straße patrouillierten in besonderen Fällen, die hatten ja keine Möglichkeit über Funkgeräte, also jedenfalls nur nicht alle. Da haben sie dann diese spezielle Nummer angewählt, die war kostenfrei von jedem Mindestveransprechern und konnten dann irgendwelche Meldungen dann durch.
Wie waren die Nummer eigentlich?
118, aber die galt nur in dem Ort, wo ich war. Also woanders war das nicht 110 und 112 und dann 118 war die Nummer dann.
Das war nicht in den Vorwahlzahlen, wo du sagst nur in meinem Ort?
Das war in dem Amtsbereich, wo ich tätig war.
Kannst du vielleicht noch ein Wort zur Vorwahlstruktur in der DDR verlieren?
Ich sage mal, die war von jedem Ort unterschiedlich. Da gab es kein einnäckliches System. Jeder Ort selber hatte ein eigenes Vorwahlregister, zum anderen Ort hin.
Das änderte sich aber auch von Zeit zu Zeit. Immer wenn man irgendwo hin im Lande verreist war und man fragte, wie man nach Berlin telefoniert, kamen solche Antworten zustande. Letztes Jahr war es die 03382, aber wie war es denn dieses Jahr?
Solche großen Städte, die hatten immer sehr kurze Vorwahlen. Also mit 0.02. Und dann waren es letztendlich immer noch eine Ziffer gewesen. Kleine Orten hatten dann mehrere Ziffern. Das hat sich wirklich wild geändert. Ich meine, das ist teilweise bis stabil oder so.
Ja, wie kam das eigentlich mit diesem unterschiedlichen Vorwahlsystem? Das ist ja eigentlich fast einzigartig.
Letztendlich waren die ja die Ente untereinander wild strukturiert. Die waren also mit einem beliebigen Netz zusammengefügt. Und ich genau weiß jetzt auch nicht, wie das zusammenhört, aber da wurde, ich hab da ein richtiges Thema gehabt, ich weiß es nicht.
Also die haben meines Wissens damals angefangen nach dem Krieg, die alten Reichspoststrukturen wieder zu rekonstruieren. Und haben dann halt irgendwie wild rumoptimiert, um halt irgendwie die Kapazitäten zwischen den Städten irgendwie einigermaßen hinzukriegen, zumindest annähernd. Und dabei kamen dann halt solche Sachen zustande. Also da gab es irgendwie die wildesten Verschaltungen. Also ich hab nach der Wende mal einen kurzen Einblick genommen in eins von diesen internen Netzen, die dann halt irgendwie tatsächlich...
Vorher sagte jetzt hier teilweise mit Gesprächen drin in der Leitung und so, dass die Hebtriwäler dann einen halben Schritt gemacht haben. Das heißt, sie haben im Prinzip zwei Leitungen miteinander überbrückt. Dadurch war man sehr oft dann in nahen Gesprächen drin. Was wir aber noch erlebt hatten, diese sogenannte Zweiertechnik mit Gums und so, haben sich dann Leute dann selber irgendwelche... Die Gums waren dann zum Schluss im Telefon drin gewesen und haben sich dann irgendwelche aus dem Westland irgendwelche Telefone geholt oder selber an die Stoffe und da hatten sie natürlich keinen Gum dran gehabt, keine Mannschaft und Scheiter und dann hatten sie mal wieder Pulswechsel am Amt. Gerade standen wir auf deren Nummer vom Nachbarn oder auf meine eigenen telefoniert oder war dann mit dem Gespräch vom Nachbarn drin gewesen. Also da gab's... Da hatte ich viel Huddlei mit gehabt letztendlich. Einige haben das mit Absicht betrieben, andere dann wirklich aus Versehen.
Ich hatte den Spaß noch bis November 1996. Hatt ich noch eine Leitung mit einem Gum. Und ich kämpfe bis heute mit der Telekom irgendwie, die irgendwie nicht anerkennen will, dass es sich dabei noch um eine Gum-Leitung handelte und mir die verminderte Grundgebühr irgendwie da in Rechnung zu stellen. Und jetzt habe ich herausbekommen, wieso. Wir haben diese verminderte Grundgebühr für Gums irgendwie seit 1.1.1997 nicht mehr in Ihrem Abrechnungssystem. Und können meine Rechnungen...
Richtig, wahrscheinlich, weil es sie offiziell wo gar nicht mehr gibt.
Richtig, genau. Deswegen können Sie meine Abrechnung halt nicht korrigieren.
Was war überhaupt mit den Kosten? Was hat ein Telefonieren im Osten gekostet?
Na also ein einmonatiges Gespräch, ein Ortsgespräch hatte 1990 den großen Nachteil, dass man irgendwie neuen Freienheiten verschwendet hat.
Oh, das verstehe ich.
Also sozusagen 20-Fenisch-Flatrate.
Also im Prinzip ein Takt Gebühren, Takt bei 18-Fenisch, so weit ich das in Erinnerung habe. Man konnte ein Ortsgespräch unendlich lange führen. Das wurde erst kassiert, nachdem aufgelegt wurde. Das war wirklich ein entscheidender Vorteil. Man konnte tagelang eine Verbindung stehen lassen und erst nach Beendigung des Gesprächs waren dann 18-Fenisch-Fälle.
Ja, aber bloß die Verbindung hat sich leider auf und zu von selbst beenden.
Ja gut, abgesehen davon. Diese Flatrate gab es ja bei uns auch, also Ortsgespräche für 20-Fenisch-Fälle. Schade, dass das Internet in der Form noch nicht so populär war, wobei dann hätte man sich auch schneller was einfallen lassen mit den Gebühren. Ingmar, was machst du heute? Hast du noch mit Telefonen zu tun?
Ja, ich bin jetzt an einer großen diakonischen Einrichtung als Techniker da noch. Carvets macht im Prinzip alles, von Verlegung bis hin zur Nebenstellentechnik, Programmierung von Telefonanlagen, die dann möglichst am Prozessor gesteuert sind.
Ja, dann wollen wir jetzt natürlich ein paar gültige Tipps für das jetzige Telefonsystem haben, nachdem sich jetzt alle geärgert haben, die im Osten gewohnt haben und gesagt haben, scheiße, hätte ich das vorher gewusst. Wobei bei 15 Fendi ist es vielleicht auch nicht so wichtig.
Oh, die Fangespräche.
Ja gut, die Fangespräche. Jetzt ein paar aktuelle Tipps vielleicht. Wir können dich ja jetzt Namen von der Redaktion geändert oder so.
Also im Moment aktuelle Tipps habe ich auch nicht drauf. Jetzt wie ich sag mal für jeden Mann, ich denke mal, die Telekom ist auch so clever, um da auch die letzten Lücken da noch zu schließen. Selbst die gefälschten Telefonkarten als solches, die jetzt hier mal aufkamen, die Telefonkarten für unendlich. Da gab es jetzt neue Software für die Mindstfernensprecher. Das weiß ich noch, weil ich noch ein bisschen Kontakt für den alten Jungs habe. Die wurden auch noch ganz schnell geändert. Und soweit ich weiß wohl nicht mehr aktuell, dass das ohne Weiteres möglich ist.
Diese Telefonkarten gehen immer noch. Gestern war der große Basterhahn.
Da haben sie schon wieder in neue Software geknackt. Da ging es ja wirklich darum, alle Münzer Eproms wechseln, neue Software aufspielen.
Meine nächste Frage gewesen, ob man das wirklich bei jeder einzelnen Telefonzelle machen muss oder ob man das irgendwie fern warten kann?
Die Dinger sind fern wartbar zu bestimmten Prozenten. Aber die Softwareänderungen im Eprom müssen vor Ort gewechselt werden. Die sind, sage ich mal, bloß verwaltbar. Fernwartung verwaltbar. Aber richtig Änderungen kann man darüber nicht nehmen. Soweit ich weiß. Genau, den Dinger stecke ich ja noch nicht mehr drin, weil ich damit nichts zu tun habe. Aber das erfährt man immer noch von den alten Kumpels. Eine Sache hätte ich vielleicht noch ganz kurz, die interessant war. Im Prinzip hatten wir in unserem Gebiet sehr viel Armee gehabt und sehr wenig Telefonanschlüsse. Die Armee wollte immer, dass sie ihre Leute erreichen können. Funktechnik war da auch nicht so verbreitet. Da haben die Folgendes gemacht. Da haben die vom Armeeobjekt über Postleitung, Sondermitleitung sich stellen lassen. Und dann wurden die in die Wohnblocks reingezogen. Und dann gab es dann objose versiegelte Kisten in den Kellerräumen, die abgeschlossen waren. Und die ging war dann angeschlossen an die Haus Klingelanlage. Und alle Offiziere und Major, die sich da in den Wohnhäusern gewohnt haben, da wurde dann ein Klingelcode über die Leitung vom Armeeobjekt ins Wohnhaus geleitet. Und dann wussten alle Bescheid, wenn dann die Klingel dann eben so einen speziellen Mosechord klingelt. Da haben sich dann alle auf die Socken gemacht und sind dann zu ihrem Objekt angefahren. So haben sie die Sachen umgangen, um ihre Leute wiederzumennachrichten. Ideen hatten sie ja auch gehabt.
Ich glaube, wenn wir noch länger mit dir plaudern, hast du wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Anekdoten auf Lager. Die Jungs haben dir hier gebannt zugehört.
Was sie auch gemacht haben mit Leidenschaft, sind diese SWF-Minze, die sind diese neueren Plastikminze gewesen, wo man dann auch Markstück und 50 Pfennig und so reinspeisen konnte. Die hatten keine Klingeln drin gehabt. Das heißt, man konnte sie angerufen, ohne dass es geklingelt hat. Und da habe ich dann, ich konnte aus meinem Amtsraum, also genau im Münzernstreich hereingucken, habe den angewählt, es hat geklingelt, es ging keiner ran, also hat man nicht gehört, abgewartet, bis eine Person kam, die den Hörer abgenommen hat. Und entweder die dann wirklich total verarscht, weil die hatte nur auf dem Zeichen gehört und gewartet und wollte dann mit Lust telefonieren. Und da war ich dran gewesen. Da sag ich ja, hallo, schon ist mit in dein roten Pullover, siehst wieder toll aus und so. Ich hab da erlebt, dass die ein höheres Fein hier das Name und raus hier ran sind.
Diese Plastikmünze hatten einen großen Vorteil, wenn man rechts oben auf diesen Vorsprung gehauen hat, dann fielen in so 80% aller Fälle die Münzen wieder unten raus, die waren eben vorher reingeschmissen.
Ja gut, dass dieser Münzspeicher, da war noch nicht so perfekt gewesen.
Und die Markstücke auch anbinden.
Genau, die Markstücke anbinden, weil die anbinden wollte.
Richtig, das haben wir auch mal probiert selber, weil wir wussten, dass das so läuft. Also wir selber als Techniker haben es nicht hingekriegt, die Dinger so wie zu manipulieren. Also da gab es noch ein paar andere Tricks. Also die Jungs hatten länger geübt als wir.
Also es gab dann, kann mich erinnern, ich hab dann so einen komischen Blechstreifen irgendwann mal geschenkt bekommen, die musste man einfach nur reinstecken. Ich fand irgendwie diesen Trick irgendwie mit dem... Ja, mit auf die Seite rufhauen, einfach so, dass da brauchte man keine anderen Methoden mehr anwenden.
Es gab auch noch einen Trick, wie die Jungs dann zu Geld gekommen sind, gleich mal die kleinen Straßenjungs, die haben dann einfach die Hörkapsel von Minze aufgeschraubt und da war ein Magnet drin. Im Prinzip der Gabelumschalter, das was aufgelegt hat, was das Gespräch beendet hat, das war magnetisch gemacht, bei den Dinger nicht richtig mechanisch, sondern magnetisch. Da hat derjenige den Magnet rausgenommen, Hörer kapselt wieder raufgeschraubt, derjenige hat Geld reingeschmissen, konnte alles endlich nicht telefonieren, ist wieder gegangen, Geld kam nicht raus, weil im Prinzip der Auflegezustand nie erreicht wurde. Dann kam der nächste, hat wieder Geld reingeschmissen, hat sich geärgert, Hörer hingehauen, Geld kam nicht raus, weil der den Auflegezustand nicht erkannt hat. Bis dann alle sich gefüllt haben, die ganzen Speicher, dann kam man dann an, Magnet rangehalten, also im Prinzip wurde er dann aufgelegt, dann kam das ganze Geld dann wieder raus, was die anderen Leute eingeschmissen haben. War schon eine ganz gängige Sache gewesen, haben da schon ein paar Spitz gekriegt.
Ingmar, wir senden jeden Mittwoch, wenn du ein paar neuere Tipps hast, rufst du an, ne?
Ich halte es für eine erstemalige Sendung, weil ich sonst normalerweise schlafe um die Zeit, aber es ist ganz interessant.
Das freut uns. Okay, dann bleib noch ein bisschen dabei.
Alles klar.
Ciao.
Gibt es eigentlich diese Telefonzentrale im Expionierpalast noch?
Ich glaube ja, die haben da unten so eine richtige mechanische Telefonanlage und glaube ich auch so eine neuere halbwegs elektronische Anlage hinter Plexiglas stehen. Da kann man halt zugucken, wie die halt vermitteln.
Und ich glaube im Museum für Verkehr und Technik steht auch noch eine.
Ja, es kann sein. Das da auch noch irgendwie so.
Das ist richtig zum Ausprobieren mit Telefonen davor.
So, da versteht man dann halt irgendwie, wie diese Wähltechnik funktioniert hat. Das war wirklich beeindruckend. Da gab es auch so Unfälle, wann irgendwie der Strom ausgefallen war und dann irgendwie die Anlage wieder angefahren wurde. Da hat allein der mechanische Hub, dieser Hebdreh, wieder ist manchmal tatsächlich geschafft, diese gesamte Anlage mechanisch zu ruinieren, wenn alle gleichzeitig runtergefahren sind.
Sven, hallo. Hast du eine kurze Geschichte? Weil in zwei Minuten das 1. Mai. Das heißt, dass wir dann irgendwie, wir machen einen kurzen 1. Mai-Feier-Song erstmal. Aber du kannst dann auch warten, so lange einfach. Das dauert nicht lange.
Das ist nach dem 1.
Mai.
Ja, ich warte dann gerne. Ich hab natürlich nicht so viel zu erzählen, wie Ingmar, aber...
Super interessant, oder?
War super interessant.
Der Mann war gut.
Schade, dass es diese Sendung nicht früher gab. Das hätte sich wahrscheinlich komisch miteinander vertragen. Du wolltest was zu Ostwest-Telefonaten sagen.
Ja, ich bin ja auch erst ab 22. Ich kann mich also noch dunkel erinnern, dass wenn uns Westverwandtschaft anrufen wollte, das vorher angemeldet hat.
Genau, das kenne ich auch von der anderen Seite.
Ja, von der anderen Seite. Das sind zu einer bestimmten Zeit, wir dann überall abgesagt haben, keiner soll uns anrufen. Und irgendwann um neun, abends, kriegen wir dann das Telefon. Das war dann die Verwandtschaft aus Hamburg, die das Gespräch vorher anmelden musste. Und da war natürlich dann Horch und Kuck in der Leitung. Und wir hatten eine andere witzige Sache. Bei uns war, also mein Onkel war geflüchtet, 81 und in den Westen. Und wir wurden überwacht und das war auch allgemein bekannt. Und mein Vater hat mit seinem Bruder telefoniert in Rostock und hat, wenn man, man hat es gehört, wenn die Leute sich reingeschaltet haben. Und hat am Ende des Gesprächs dann meist ein Gruß an die Stadt Sicherheit und die armen Säue müssen ja jetzt Weihnachten da sitzen und horchen. Und vor einer Weile hat er seine Akten einbeantragt. Und da sind dann also Gespräche mit Schriften dabei und dann hat diejenige, der es gehört hat, dann aufgeschrieben, ja, Herr Behrendt hat die Genossen der Stadt Sicherheit gegrüßt und sich vor Weihnachten gefühlt hat. Also es war wirklich schön. Und der andere Kiste war auch, dass wir einen Gemeinschaftsanschluss hatten mit den Nachbarn und dann auch stets und ständig uns gegenseitig blockiert haben und in den Gesprächen drin waren.
Ja, aber schöne Geschichte.
Hat die Kollegen der Staatssicherheit gegrüßt? Die Genossen wahrscheinlich, ne?
Ja, die Genossen, ja. Also es war sein Bruder, der war teilweise ein bisschen schärfer und hat teilweise so ein bisschen auf die Leute geschimpft. Aber das war, wie gesagt, dann alles niedergeschrieben. Im Übrigen finde ich es schon ziemlich krass, jetzt schon so zusammen zu sitzen und über die Vergangenheit zu lachen und zu sagen, wisst ihr noch damals?
Ja, aber es ist wahrscheinlich...
Es ist krass so, es ist so wie Krückstock in der Hand und ach Mensch und...
Na ja, wisst ihr noch damals, aber das ist natürlich, ich weiß schon, was du meinst, aber eigentlich ist es ja, wenn man zum Beispiel über diese Computer redet, das ist nicht unbedingt ein Ostwest-Ding, also Computertechnologie ist halt einfach so schnell, dass man da 10 Jahre später immer wahrscheinlich drüber schmunzeln würde. Mal sehen, was wir in 10 Jahren für Sendungen machen. Wobei.
Sven, ich danke dir für diese lustige Anekdote. Bis dann.
Der nächste Song ist dem Beginn des allgemeinen Kampf-und-Feiertages der Werktätigen gewidmet, nämlich dem 1. Ich bin der Beste von allen.
Ihr hört Chaosradio, das Chaoscomputer, den Chaoscomputer Blumen hier bei Fritz. Und jetzt gibt es die Chaosradio.
Kurzmeldungen.
Finnland, alle Züge im südlichen Teil Finnland stand am 12. April für eine Stunde still, weil der Verkehrsleitcomputer ausgefallen war. Als Ursache wurde eine Büroklammer in der Tastatur des Backup Computers ausgemacht, die durch merkwürdige Software Umstände zu einem Plattenüberlauf führte. Bedingt durch den nun erreichten nicht deterministischen Systemzustand, fing der Backup-Rechner an, den Hauptcomputer zu belästigen, bis dieser gegen vollständig zum Stehen kam. Bislang gibt es noch keine Hinweise auf ein allgemeines Büroklammerverbot in Finnland. Hamburg. Am Sonntag gab die Bundesanwaltschaft durch ihr Zentralorganbild. Am Sonntag bekannt, dass ein 23-jähriger Hamburger im dringenden Verdacht steht, deutsche Flughäfen um 50 Millionen Mark erpressen zu wollen. Der oder die Täter hatten gedroht, ein springstoffgefülltes Modellflugzeug in den Triebwerkeinlass eines startenden Flugzeugs zu lenken und dieses so zum Absturz zu bringen. Die Forderungen wurden über E-Mails an das Verkehrsministerium gestellt. Offenbar wurde dabei ein sogenannter Remailer benutzt, der E-Mails anonymisiert. Der Tatverdächtige wurde durch intensive Recherchen im Internet, Zuarbeit eines Internetproviders und großzügige Hilfe amerikanischer Sicherheitsbehörden identifiziert. Amerikanische Geheimdienste stehen seit längerem im Verdacht, Remailer selbst zu betreiben oder mit Hilfe ihrer weltumspannenden Abhörnetze zu beobachten. Tätverdächtige sah es lustigerweise zum Zeitpunkt der Identifizierung schon wegen Steuerhinterziehung im Gefängnis. Moskau. In einem vertraulichen Papier kolportieren Mitarbeiter der deutschen Botschaft in Moskau eine ziemlich komische Geschichte, die prompt den Weg auf die Zitelblätter der Boulevardblätter fand. Ein japanisches Fischerboot sei von einer vom Himmel fallenden Kuh versenkt worden. Die Kuh sei aus einem Transportflugzeug zusammen mit einigen ihrer Artgenossen abgeworfen worden. Russische Soldaten hätten die Herde geklaut und beim Abtransport vergessen, die Rindviecher festzubinden. Als sie dann unruhig wurden, blieb der Abwurf als letzter Ausweg. Im Internet finden sich interessanterweise eine identische Geschichte vom Februar 1995. Hier war zwar das Flugzeug amerikanisch, der Fischer ein Russe auf dem kaspischen Meer und der Kuhflug ein Hilfstransport, aber die Kuh versenkte auch hier ein Fischerboot. Das Auswärtige Amt war bisher für eine Stellungnahme nicht zu erreichen. Bonn. Bundesinnenminister Kanter hat auf dem Jahreskongress des Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik die Einführung eines Verschlüsselungsverbotes gefordert. Begründet wurde dies mit der Gefährdung durch fiese organisierte Kriminelle, die die Grundfesten des Staates, des Eigentums und der nationalen Sicherheit bedrohten. Kanter erntete schon auf dem Kongress harte Kritik von Experten und Wirtschaftsvertretern. Selbst der Junior- Partner in der Regierungskoalition FDP erinnerte sich seiner Klientin und schloss eine Zustimmung zu jeder Regulierung von Kryptografie strikt aus. Microsoft hat heftige Probleme mit dem Microsoft Network, kurz MSN. Durch einen starken Anstieg der E-Mail-Nutzung fielen die Server für die Usernamen mit diversen Anfangsbuchstaben aus. Nach zwei Tagen mit Neustarts und wiederholten Abstürzen, die zu heftigen Kundenbeschwerden führten, schaltete Microsoft den Mail-Service kurzerhand für zwei Tage ab, um den Fehler zu beheben. Wie viele Kunden MSN diese Aktion gekostet hat ist unbekannt. Ihr braucht noch nicht schlafen. Live Übertragung hier bei Fritz. Ihr hört im Moment noch Chaosradio, den Chaos Computer Club Blue Moon bei Fritz. Und wir reden über Osttechnologie. Wir hatten das Thema Ostcomputer, diverse Modelle mit vielen tollen Buchstaben und so ein, haben wir besprochen. Wir haben über Osttelefonie gesprochen. Ich glaube, da hat Ingmar eine ganze Menge Sachen erzählt, die selbst den Chaos Computer Club hier noch zum Staunen gebracht haben. Und nähern uns jetzt einem anderen Thema, nämlich den schönen drei Buchstaben D, F, Ü, bevor das alles mit Internet und mit Mailboxen kam. Natürlich damals auch, dafür waren sie ja dann da für die Datenfernübertragung, nämlich D, F, Ü hieß das alles. Man hatte keine Modems, sondern ein Akustikkoppler, also so ein bisschen wie ein negativer Telefonhörer, auf den hat dann auch derselbe raufgepasst. Und die Töne, die man auch jetzt beim Einloggen in irgendwelche Netze noch am Anfang ein bisschen hören kann, oder die man auch von Faxen kennt, diese Datenübertragung, also die wurde da einfach mittels Lautsprecher und Telefonhörer übertragen, zumindest bei uns im Westen. Im Osten sicher auch, oder?
Naja, also im Osten war die Sache mit der D, F, Ü, halt so eine Sache, weil erstens war die Hardware echt noch rar, also es gab wirklich kaum Leute, die irgendwie Modems oder Akustikkoppler hatten. Naja, und dann war halt die Sache sehr unsicher, ob man es dann überhaupt durfte, also eigentlich durfte man es bestimmt nicht. Und was mit denen passierte, die es tatsächlich gemacht haben, ist auch so ein bisschen unbekannt. Also es gab im Osten ja auch nicht wirklich Faxe, muss man dazu sagen. Fax war irgendwie, naja, gab es halt praktisch nicht so. Es gab halt irgendwie Telex.
Aber Fax ging auch erst so Mitte der 80er eigentlich los. Ja, aber Fax war auch unerschwinglich für Privatleute.
Ja, war praktisch unbekannt so im Osten. Und naja, diese DFÜ-Geschichte ging eigentlich erst 1990 richtig los, als viele Leute dann sich billige Modems oder billige Akustikkuppler gekauft haben. Und dann sprießt du auf die Mailbox hier im Osten noch auf der Basis von diesem hübschen Flatrate-Ortstarif doch relativ schnell. Und dann standen halt irgendwie Mailboxen aller Art, also von normalen vernetzten Cerberus- oder CL-Netzmehlboxen bis hin zu düsteren Traderboxen, die halt irgendwie Software noch in Löcher durch die Gegend geschoben haben. Da gab es dann alles und einige haben ja offenbar, wie wir vorhin gehört haben, tatsächlich auch überlebt.
Also 1990 gab es noch keinen Unterschied zwischen normalen und Traderboxen.
Stimmt, da gab es noch nicht wirklich diesen Unterschied.
Was heißt Traderbox?
Trader, also Leute, die halt Software durch die Gegend schieben. So stimmt, das kann ich noch an die Download-Area verinnern.
Seit 1991 oder 1992 konnte man aus der ehemaligen DDR 0113 Nummern erreichen und die waren damals halt relativ schlecht gegen Blue Boxing abgesichert. Deswegen gab es da relativ gute Möglichkeiten, sich dann halt weltweit das Zeug zu besorgen.
Also dieser Zusammenschluss dieser beiden Telefonsysteme hatte auch irgendwie doch relativ viel spaßige Seiten.
Wenn ihr Erfahrungen mit DFÜ habt, mit Mailboxen im Osten, dann ruft uns an 0331 für Potsdam 74 181 110. Und eigentlich habe ich natürlich auch den hier dafür.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist gescheitert. 0331 für Potsdam 74 81 110.
Und ich hab sie gesehen. Und ich hab sie gesehen. Und ich hab sie gesehen. Und ich hab sie gesehen.
Und ich hab sie gesehen. Und ich hab sie gesehen.
Und ich hab sie gesehen.
Ich hab mir eben überlegt und ich möchte gerne meine Ausstellung dann darüber machen. Und nun ist es so, ich habe schon viele Geräte und würde gerne noch viele mehr haben wollen.
Da bist du glaube ich nicht der Einzige, der sammelt. Wir haben hier samstags immer die Fritz-Börse, wo so Leute tauschen oder an und Verkauf machen. Da gibt es viele Leute, die alte Radiogeräte sammeln. Du kannst ja mal einen Kontakt durchgeben, wo man sich melden soll.
Also Telefon Berlin 030 55 99 44 6.
Die Nummer hätte ich auch gerne. Axel, gut, ich sag die Nummer auch nochmal durch dann. Du sammelst zu DDR hauptsächlich Rundfunkgeräte für eine Ausstellung.
Ja, das hängt auch damit zusammen. Ich hab ja nur eine kleine Wohnung, eine 2-Ruhr-Wohnung. Und wenn man da noch Fernseher sammeln wollte, also dann müsste man anbauen. Und das geht im Hochhaus schlecht. Also von der Wartung her muss man sich als solche drauf beschränken und ich würde mich irgendwie darum kümmern. Vielleicht hier bei Saturn in Berlin habe ich mir schon überlegt oder so. Vielleicht irgendwie nebenher eine Ausstellung darüber zu machen.
Na wir geben die Nummer gleich nochmal durch und dann rufen dich alle Leute an, die da was noch zu beizutragen haben.
Danke erst auch.
Bis denn, ciao.
Also immerhin Glück, weil es ist ein abgeschlossenes Sammelgebiet.
Axels Telefonnummer für Leute, die da noch was beizusteuern haben, ist in Berlin die 5599 446 5599446. Schön, einfach eine Nummer. Jens ist am Telefon.
Hi Jens.
Hi, ich bin's wieder.
Ach, du nochmal. Genau.
Wir hatten auch damals auch 91 im Grunde kurz nach der Wende angefangen unsere Boxen aufzubauen. Haben wir auch ein Jahr Abenteuer erlebt. Und zwar, sag ich mal, angefangen hat alles mal auf der Cocon 90, diesem Communications-Kongress, wo, glaube ich, Micha war das damals, ein Terminalprogramm für Kc vorgestellt hatte. Verbindung nach Holland oder was ihr da aufgebaut habt. Na gut, so ein Jahr später, so 91 im September, 1. September, ging unsere 1.
Box online.
Damals mit 2, 4 Modem, M&P 5, schon ganz luxuriös ausgestattet. Aber hat natürlich auf den DDR-Leitungen herzhaft wenig gebracht. Die Strecke nach Westberlin lief einigermaßen stabil, aber alles, was wir innerhalb von Ostberlin machen wollten, sind die Leitungen nach 300 Kilobyte immer zusammengebrochen wegen dieser mechanischen Wähler.
Die einzigen Modems, die für Verbindungen innerhalb der ehemaligen DDR-Einigen machen, waren halt diese Dreieckbläserteile.
Genau, und deswegen hatten wir dann auch offen 2500 abgerätet später.
Was hatte die zu Anfang für Modems?
Das waren Discovery 2400 oder 2400CM.
Das war alles, ich war richtiges MNP-5.
Nein, mein Modem konnte kein MNP-5, aber es gab glücklicherweise ein Terminal-Programm mit MNP-5. Keine Ahnung, wie das hieß. Minicom?
Also wir haben noch Dialoge in der Box liegen, das ist ein ganz alter Terminal, was noch ein MNP-5 emulieren konnte.
Was habt ihr damals so gehabt auf der Box? Ich meine, ihr habt doch bestimmt auch...
Wir haben uns dann mit Cerberus ins Z-Netz reingehängt, hauptsächlich so Informationsaustausch gefahren, dass die Leute auch so ein bisschen rennschnuppern konnten.
Und wie viele User hattet ihr da so?
Also angefangen hat es mit drei, vier Usern. Und inzwischen sind wir so bei 70 angekommen, 70, 80.
Habt ihr noch die alten User-Listen? Ich versuche mich gerade zu erinnern, ob ich Kalypso mal mich eingewählt habe oder nicht. Sag mal Passwort. Oh, keine Ahnung. Ich glaub damals als Andreas.
Ja, das fing so an und dann so 92 wurde es dann schon ein bisschen mehr, dass man so auf 10, 11 hochgeschrottet wurde. Wie gesagt, das war für ein paar Kumpels erst gedacht und trotzig dann immer mehr...
Die Kukorn 90 war da tatsächlich so eine Art Initialzündung.
Das müssen wir mal wieder machen in Berlin.
Ja, wir haben darüber nachgedacht, ein Kongress in Berlin zu machen. Wir machen uns zwar im Pionierpalast im Sommer, aber da diesen Sommer die Holländer in Holland eine Party im Grünen machen, und zwar die... Hipp heißt sie diesmal? Ja, genau, die Hipp, haben wir uns entschlossen, dieses Jahr halt kein Kongress im Sommer, also in Berlin, zu machen. Aber wir denken da schon darüber nach, vielleicht nächstes Jahr oder so. Mal gucken. Also nach Holland irgendwie lohnt es sich auf jeden Fall zu kommen, weil da wird es wieder sehr spaßig werden.
Aber jetzt muss ich mal dazu sagen, und zwar wurde vorhin gesagt, dass also diese Trader-Boxen und Zauberer-Systeme so ein bisschen in einen Top geworfen wurden.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es natürlich Leute gab, die die Hierophane irgendwie des Ehrlichseins umgehalten haben und da irgendwie keine Trader-Geschichten gemacht haben. Aber die meisten Freak-Boxen im Osten waren, bis irgendwie die rechtliche Lage allen einigermaßen bewusst wurde, tatsächlich auch noch irgendwie mit Trader-Boxen war im Westen nicht anders. Also da hat sich niemand irgendwie schuldig gefühlt, wenn da irgendwie ein bisschen Software drauf rumliegen hat. Also da lässt sich heute, glaube ich, auch niemand mehr wirklich einen Vorwurf draus konstruieren. Es gab ja halt dann fürs Anschluss- oder Beitrittsgebiet sogar eine Amnestie-Erklärung.
Genau, die Tobopascal-Amnestie.
Genau, oder AutoCAD.
Weil sie sich für ein paar hundert Mark lizenziert haben, was?
Genau, also für Tobopascal gab es sogar eine Voll-Amnestie oder so.
Nein, es gab ein kostenloses Upgrade. Das heißt, wenn man früher eine Rauchkopie im Osten hatte, kam man eine Vollversuchung.
Jens, vielen Dank.
Und weiter viel Spaß. Jetzt kommen wir auf verschiedenste Technologien. Rudi ist am Apparat und wir erzählen etwas über sich und seinen alten Ostfernseher. Hi Rudi.
Also, meine Eltern haben dort Fernseher. Das ist ein ziemlich altes Teil, so Fabrikat Strasbourg. Also, mit dem ich eigentlich groß geworden bin, schon hab ich noch in der Winde gelegen.
Ja, Rudi, hast du eine lustige Geschichte oder wolltest du nur erzählen?
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ich war so zehn Jahre. Das war eine Winterferne. Und ich war krank gewesen. Und den ganzen Tag Fernsehen geguckt. Und auf jeden Fall fing das Ding an zu qualmen. War arschgemacht irgendwie. Und damals war es immer so mit die Fernsehdienste, die haben ja schon ein, zwei, drei Tage gebraucht, als sie mal gekommen sind. Und ich hab das immer beim Fernsehen geguckt. Auf jeden Fall. Das war es eigentlich gewesen.
Was ich heute habe Spaß.
Hat seine Entwicklung aber nicht geschadet, denke ich.
Vielleicht hättest du den anderen Harnssonnen, den ich eigentlich spielen wollte. 0331 für Potsdam, 7418, 1100 ist unsere Nummer hier. Wir reden über Osttechnologien, jetzt Freestyle, würde ich sagen. Da kann jetzt keiner mitlachen, schade. Nochmal Nina Hagen. Was denn? René haben wir einmal über Telefon und Computer und dann nochmal Ingmar über DDR Unterhaltungselektronik. Das wird spannend. Da wir aber gleich einen Fritz-Kurz-Info haben, fangen wir erst mal mit René an und gucken wie weit wir kommen. Hallo René.
Achso, ich muss aber zusagen, ich konnte nicht die ganze Zeit zusagen, weil ich mal zwischendurch arbeiten muss und dann irgendwelche Leute bedienen muss. Dann wird es halt laut. Ich? Tankstellen-Heini. Nee und wir, Telefon. Insofern spaße ich auf den Höfen, diese Halo-Kraugus-Kästen in Ostberlin. Und ich kannte sehr viele Leute, die hatten immer einen Telefonhörer mit einer W-Scheibe in der Hosentasche gehabt oder in ihrem Jägerhirsch-Leihenbeutel. Und wenn es dann ganz dringend wurde und man irgendwie überhaupt nicht mehr klar kam mit Partys oder der Meinung war, jetzt müsste es doch eigentlich ganz gut von der Zeit her passen, mal nach Westberlin, man kommt durch, ist man halt auf dem Hof gestiegen, auf irgendeine Blechtrommel, Blechmülltonne ran an den Kasten, sich angeklemmt mit Krokodilklemmen und wie weltruflos gewählt.
Das kennt ihr auch noch.
Das gibt es auch immer noch in einigen Stadtplätzen in Berlin, wenn die Verteilerkästen immer noch auf Brusttüren montiert.
Ja und dann noch das andere war, diese Geschichte, wenn man bei Freunden war, die ein Telefon hatten, dass man eben versucht hat, die Wählscheibe zu blockieren, wir hatten ja auch davon auch schon mal gesprochen, Stasi und so, also dass man die Wählscheibe mit irgendwas blockiert, aber man hat irgendeine Nummer gewählt und die Wählscheibe nicht zurücklaufen lassen, sondern im Zuzug offen gehalten, und war dann der festen Meinung, dass die Stasi nicht mithören kann.
Na ja gut, also...
Ich glaube, ich in seiner Rubrik aber glaube nicht.
Genau, da haben wir irgendwie einen hübschen Gag gehabt, nach der Wende gab es diese Testnummer, die zurückgerufen und geklingelt hat und wurde dann irgendwie die Legende verbreitet von irgendjemanden, dass wenn es dann klingelt, dann wurde seine Leitung abgehackt.
Ja, und die andere Geschichte war die gewesen, auch noch Telefon. Wenn man ein Telefon hatte, so wie ich, was immer schon ganz verdächtig war, wenn man dann plötzlich ein Telefon bekommen hat in einer Gegend, wo sonst kaum jemand ein Telefon neu bekommen hat, da wusste man schon, da ist irgendwas im Busch. Aber das, was insofern, wie gesagt, lustig war, wenn man dann Anrufe von seinem Chef bekommen hatte, brauchte man nur bestimmte Stichworte sagen, zum Beispiel Tatort oder Scheißwechselkurs. Also vollkommen unzusammenhörlos. Meistens ist dann die Leitung sofort danach zusammengebrochen. Man konnte sich so den Chef am Wochenende vom Hals halten. Da hat sie zwar immer gewundert, warum man gerade solche Sachen sagte, irgendwie, was hatte das Wort Tatort zu tun? Da dachte sie, ich wollte gerade erzählen, dass ich eigentlich einen tollen Film gesehen hatte und hatte nur das Stichwort erst mal so. Und dann, ja, das war einer der besten Späße gewesen, um sich sozusagen vor Sondereinsätzen, zum Beispiel, wenn man gerufen wurde in die Firma.
Oh, so leicht enttiefst.
Ja, und dann noch eine andere Geschichte, die mir noch eingefallen ist. Ihr hattet erstens über DDR-Computer und solche Geschichten gesprochen, ne? Glaube ich, ganz zu Anfang. Einer meiner Lieblingsbezugsquellen ist in Köpenick die Stadtreinigungshöfe. Und zwar gibt es da einen, wie nennt man den? In Köpenick, oder Quatsch, in der Nähe vom Espanol-Spindler-Felder ist der.
Und da finden wir noch alte, oft Geschichten oder was?
Und das findest du in den Schrottcontainern für Elektronik, also ich hab mir letztens wieder diese externen Laufwerke für diese riesen Flippy-Discs mitgenommen von dort. Und die sind so schön stabil sind halt, einmal gut aussehen und zum anderen auch recht spaßig sind so als Erläuterungsmaterial die Traditionsecke sag ich mal.
Nach dem Tipp wirst du da wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht mehr viel finden oder zumindest viele gleichgesinnte Anträge.
Das ist kein Problem, weil andere haben jetzt im Treptow und in Kürbinecker Straße im Mitte soll es ähnlich aussehen. Weil in vielen, vielen Betrieben, die jetzt in Konkurs gehen oder neue Eigenthimer gefunden haben oder so was, werden die Dinger von den Hausmeistern aus dem Keller geholt und zum größten Teil werden sie in kompletten Zustand halt angeliefert.
Gut, René, dann erstmal danke für die Tipps.
Ach so, ja, genau, Nachrichten.
Soweit René und wir machen hier einen fliegenden Wechsel.
Wenn Fritz in Angermünde, dann 100, 1.
0 uhr 31.
Entscheidungen in Großbritannien wird heute ein neues Parlament gewählt. Es gilt als sicher, dass die reformierte Labour-Partei von Tony Blair die Konservativen von Premierminister Major ablöst. Aktion Armenische Kurden haben gestern die USA-Botschaft in Bonn besetzt. Sie wollten damit ihre Abschiebung aus Deutschland verhindern, die etwa 20 Männer, Frauen und Kinder verließen, am Abend freiwillig das Gebäude. Luftbrücke die UNO hat gestern die ersten ruandischen Hutu-Flüchtlinge aus Ost-Zair ausgeflogen, darunter viele Waisenkinder. Insgesamt sollen fast 100.000 Menschen wieder in ihre Heimat gebracht werden. Urteil, die rechtsextreme NPD darf heute zum 1. Mai in Leipzig nicht demonstrieren. Dies entschied am Abend in letzter Instanz das sächsische Oberverwaltungsgericht. Dennoch werden Auseinandersetzungen befürchtet. Mayday in Dortmund begann am Abend das alljährliche Techno-Spektakel. Die Veranstalter erwarten bis zu 20.000 Fans auf der 16-stündigen Dauerfete mit rund 40 Live-Acts und DJs aus Europa, den USA und Japan. Fußball in einem Qualifikationsspiel zur Weltmeisterschaft 1998 gewann Deutschland gegen die Ukraine mit 2 zu 0.
Wetter.
Nachts kaum Regen, 9 bis 5 Grad, tagsüber meist heiter und trocken, 15 bis 18 Grad.
Verkehr.
Da liegen weiterhin keine Meldungen vor.
Die Reitplatte Heinrichs mit dem Fritz-Kurz-Info.
Pop-Funk, Hip-Hop-Store, Hip-Techno, Dab-Radio.
Direkt aus dem Club und mitten ins Stereoradio. Diese Woche live von der Insel Berlin-Tretto mit Atmosphäre Trip-Hop von Skor an den Decks das PCM Soundsystem, Moonraker und die Bass-Terra Crew.
Jungs, an die Instrumente. Wir machen gleich fliegend weiter. Ohne Musik dazwischen, weil Ingmar am Apparat ist und dann Benjamin. Hallo Ingmar.
Ja, ich bin noch mal...
Der Ingmar von vorhin.
Ja, genau. Irgendwie wollte ich was sagen zu einer Alumnelektronik, aber ich wollte noch mal ganz kurz anknüpfen an meinen Vorredner, der irgendwas von Stadion und Telefon erzählt hat. Es gab wirklich, was ich auch sehr gut erlebt habe, eine gängige Methode, Leute übers Telefon abzuhören. Und zwar sind die einfach hingegangen, haben sich dann als deutsche Post vorgestellt, haben dann über den Galum-Schalter, wo man normalerweise aufliegt und dann alles unterbrochen ist, einen Widerstand eingelötet, sodass immer noch ein ganz schwacher Strom geflossen ist, der über das Mikrofon. Dann haben sich am nächsten Straßenverteiler dann auf ihre Sonderleitung raufgeklemmt und so konnten sie auch mit aufgelegtem Telefon die Gespräche im Raum abhören. Das war so eine ganz einfache, aber doch sehr wachungsvolle Sache gewesen.
Meistens haben sie dann dazu die Kohlekapseln gegen dynamische Kapseln ausgetauscht.
Wir hatten dann PEC-Mikrofone gehabt, dynamische weniger, aber PEC-Mikrofone, die hatten dann kein Eigenrauschnern mehr gehabt. Und noch mal zu den Mitschnitten von der Stadt Seagard. Also mir ist bekannt soweit, was man nachher mitgekriegt hat, dass die meisten Gespräche gar nicht live abgehört worden sind. Die sind auf Bändern mitgeschnitten worden, datiert worden. Und wenn es dann irgendwelche Fälle gab, dann war immer ein Datum interessant. Und dann wurden dann die entsprechenden Bänder rausgesucht und dann der Inhalt dann analysiert.
Es gab da so schicke 19 Zoll Schränke mit die Volt 200 Rekordern drin.
Richtig, ich hab mal so ein Ding mal in dem Bastel dann gesehen, die Einschübe dann davon.
Hochqualitativer Rekorder.
Ja, also mit drei Motoren drin, voll elektronisch ansteuerbar. Also da war so jeder andere DDR-Rekorder, konnte sich dann da verstecken.
Nach der Wende billig zu haben.
Was ich sagen wollte, damals gab es so einen HarmCut 200. Das war der erste digital programmierbare Thuner Radio. Und letztendlich war damals auch in der Elektronikbranche noch ein bisschen tätig und abgeschafft. In Zusammenarbeit mit dem...
gerade so rausgebracht, und haben dann die beschafft, von Sternradio dann diese Schaltkreise.
Haben wir jetzt einen Schritt Mikrorechner dann noch beschafft, mit einem Pass in EEPROM dazu, der programmiert wurde in Assemblern. Kumpel hat das noch gemacht. Und dadurch doch tatsächlich mein Digital-Thuner, also mit TLL, und Voll-Infrarot-Fernbedienung eher fertig gehabt, als wirklich die DR mit ihrem Hamk 200 auf den Markt kam. Ich war da in einer Bude gewesen. Wir haben letztendlich für einen Elektronik-Service in Berlin Geräte entwickelt und gebaut, spezielle Prüf- und Messgeräte. Ganz speziell auf die entsprechenden Rundfunk- und Fernbedienung abgestimmt. Da wurde auch privat gebaut nebenbei. Und wenn dann irgendwelche Betriebsleitern vorbei kamen, wurde dann meine Privatarbeit als hochwissenschaftliche von diesen Abteilungen dargestellt. Das war ganz lustig gewesen.
Bei den Messgeräten gab es ja diese Geschichten, dass HP-Messgeräte gerade von den Russen in großem Maßstab nachgebaut wurden. Und da haben wir jetzt nach der Wende festgestellt, dass irgendwie bei vielen dieser Messgeräte einfach die Einschübe direkt kompatibel sind. Also die kannst du halt aus so einem großen HP-Ostylographen einfach mal einen Schub rausnehmen und in diesen Russental reinstecken und der rennt halt so.
Na ja, das war eigentlich erstmal allzweck noch.
Der Mann ist aktiv, ne? Das ist ja ein Interessant, was man so erfährt, wa?
Ja, allerdings.
Also ich wollte nur eben sagen, also einige Kategorien Ehebemerkung, als ich an dir rufen habe, und zwar eure 32-Bit-Technik, die eher die Räume füllte. Stimmt ja nicht, wa? War ja an sich nur Schlafzimmergröße, wenn ich mal so sagen soll. Also unser 32-Bit-Recher, den wir hatten bei uns, der war kurz im Schlafzimmerschrank und auf dem lief komischerweise vorm S.
Wie hieß denn der?
Ach, weiß ich nicht mehr.
Ist schon ewig her.
So nur so eine Hüftehoherkiste, oder war die volle hoch?
Jedes war die volle Hüftehoherkiste, nicht die Hüftehoherkiste. Aber die hat die gleiche Rechenleistung gehabt wie eine Vex, glaube ich, die wir auch bei uns stehen hatten. Wir hatten einen Vex-Klaster gehabt von vier Vexen und die konnten wir problemlos mit dranhängen. Also unseren 32-Bit-Rechner von Robotron konnten wir problemlos mit dranhängen, war ohne Probleme möglich. Original IBM Festzattelstrecke an unseren Großrechner, Marke ESA. Also nicht ESA, sondern ESA.
Das sind die 1022 oder was? Wo hast du gearbeitet?
Im Rechenzentrum, im Institut für Nachrichtentechnik. Das war eine weile gewesen. Da musste man durch zwei Co-Türen durchgehen, bevor man weg zum Rechenzentrum einkommen konnte. Aber ist ja nur nebenwächlich, darüber darf ich ja gar nicht reden, weil es ja nicht das Thema ist.
Das finde ich immer sehr interessant, wo überall diese Kisten standen. Gerade auch die schwarz importierten Wechseln. Ich hatte da mal so ein Erlebnis, ich weiß gar nicht mal wo es war, da war halt praktisch...
Da standen noch weite, so weit ich wies. Und im Funkverkehr bin ich, so weit ich wies, so hoch, also 1 oder 2, aber das weiß ich nicht genau. Wir hatten eine riesen, große Wechsel, ich weiß nicht, 8, 8, noch was, keine Ahnung mehr. Dann noch ein Backbone und vier andere Wechseln dran und dann eben diesen 32-bit-Rechner von uns und original 40-100 und 40-240.
Und auf dem Robotron lief richtig Formel S drauf?
Ja, lief 100% Formel S drauf, weil der hing voll im Cluster mit drin. Geh ihm ein Problem und hat auch ein bisschen Leistungsressourcen mitgenommen, so was man. Wir hatten auch original ein Alte-Monitor rüber und stehen, mussten wir auch dazu.
War nicht schlecht.
Also ihr seid sozusagen in der Quelle, ja.
Ich wies nicht, ob wir in der Quelle waren, ich meine, ich war dann auch stift gewesen damals. Oh Gott, damals, 25 Jahre alt und so. Weil damals hatten wir es vorhin schon mal gehabt. Aber es war schon eine Wahnsinnzeit, wenn man sich überlegt, als wir das erste Mal zu der Tür hin kamen und dann diese ganzen Techniker stehen liegen hatten.
Also ich kann mich noch erinnern, ich war irgendwo im Praktikum und da haben wir Rechner ausgepackt. Und zwar kamen die mit dem Wagen einer österreichischen Theaterkompanie an. Und es war eine originale LBM 360 oder 370. Die war halt nicht mehr eine Originalverpackung. Und wir mussten dann irgendwie die Tannenladen aus den Lüftungsschlitzen rauspeulken, die sich da beim Umladen festgehakt hatten.
Das sind so australische Tierchen.
Da fragte ich mich, das war so diese Grafikmode, die wir hatten. Und da fragte ich mich, wo die Rechner herkamen. Ich hab's nie erfahren. Gut haben sie wahrscheinlich uns Schlellinge auch nicht überall informiert. Aber noch eine andere Sache, das ist mir gerade so eingefallen bei dem Vorredner. Mein erster Rechner nach der Wende war ein BT 5120, soweit ich weiß. Das ist ein Bürofabier.
Der mit den dreides Kettenlaufwerken.
Ja, 1.8-Verlaufwerk dabei.
Und lief problemlos. Also im 6-Motor war das gewesen. Das CPM war das irgendwie.
Ich glaube, es gab Wörz da dafür.
Und Reda Bass.
Und gab es für den Turbo Pascal? Nee, für den gab es keinen Turbo Pascal.
Doch, den Pascal habe ich nicht gehabt, da war Reda Bass. Also dieses DBS, dieses DBS 3. Er lief auch eine ganze Weile bei mir, so ein halbes Jahr. Und dann hat er einen Geist aufgegeben.
Das ist ein bisschen schwer.
Das war ein ganzer Tisch gewesen an sich, wenn man es so gesehen hat.
Was hast du heute auf dem Tisch als Rechner?
4x86er, 80 Mhz, mit groß, groß, groß vier Platte und vier Betriebssystem. Aber ansonsten ist er nicht.
Eigentlich ist ein PC sehr langweilig.
Ich erinnere mich an gute alte Zeiten zurück, wo man seine Kc 85 hier, welcher waren das, die man selber, die man selber zusammenschrauben konnte, weiß ich nicht mehr. Irgendetwas kommt noch selber zusammen.
Das war der Z 1013, ja. Ja, hängen wir. Das war auch mal eine wirklich prägende Maschine für viele Leute.
Das war eine prägende Maschine, aber der Unterschied war, dass wir in der theoretischen Ausbildung im DVZ, also im Datenverarbeitungszentrum, Kc 85, den hatten, treffe im Lehrkabinett 128 D. Ja, mir wollte ich eigentlich nicht erzählen.
Benjamin, Dankeschön.
Ach, Altherren treffen hier, ne?
So ein bisschen.
Ja, aber das war natürlich vorhin durchaus richtige Bemerkung. So lange ist das alles noch gar nicht und Benjamin hat auch gerade gesagt 25 oder was? Benjamin ja, 25 und aber schon von früher reden. Hannes ist dran, 27 und redet wahrscheinlich auch von früher, von Stasi und Osttechnik.
Hannes?
Ja, ich bin eigentlich ein bisschen enttäuscht, dass ihr heute da nichts mal zum 1. Mai macht.
Naja, hat auch nichts mit der Sendung zu tun.
Nee, eigentlich nicht, aber ihr haltet euch ja immer so für so ein alternatives Radio, das kommt immer zumindest so rüber. Deswegen.
Also A hat der erste Mal ja vor einer dreiviertel Stunde angefangen, also solltest du morgen vielleicht den ganzen Tag Radio hören.
Nee, da bin ich auf der Demo.
Ja, super. Auf welcher denn?
Ja, deswegen, ja, deswegen, das wollte ich ja nochmal sagen, dass alle Leute, die jetzt frist hören, unbedingt heraus zum revolutionären Mai, Revival von dem Kiezaufstand 87, 13 Euro, der Luxemburgplatz oder Oranienplatz.
Tja, so weit der Aufruf zur Weltrevolution?
Ja, und so weit der Aufruf zum, wo bist du nur geboren? Ansonsten, da machst du praktisch so ein bisschen so Show für die Touristen.
Show für die Touristen? Glaubst du, ihr habt so viele Touristenzuhörer?
Nee, aber hier haben wir auch bestimmt viele Touristenzuschauer. So Krawall-Tourismus nennt man das.
Das ist doch nichts Übles, oder?
Auf dem Krollwitzplatz in den Schauspielstern.
Das ist doch Ressentigkeit, das ist Medien. Das brauchen wir.
Super.
Für welche Sache denn ihr?
Na, für die Verbesserung der Welt, für die soziale Revolution.
Klingt gut. Dann noch viel Spaß für die Weltrevolution, würde ich sagen.
Ja, die Welt am Morgen erleben.
Alles klar, alles klar.
Ja, da kann man mal sehen, dass...
Ihr ein beidverfechertes Publikum habt.
alternative Konzepte auch nicht immer mehr Inhalte haben, als die, die wir von unseren hohen Herren bekommen. Olli ist dran. Hallo, Olli. Mach mal dein Radio aus, Olli.
Ja, ja, hab ich gerade gemacht.
Hallo, ja. Ihr hattet gerade den 1413 kurz erwähnt, diesen Einblattdienst, hat 80 Rechner. Da gab es eine lustige Story, ich hab 85 im WF gearbeitet und im Werk für Fernsehelektronik, wo da die LEDs und die Bildröhren gemacht wurden. Und da hatten wir Anlagen, die arbeiteten mit Verschieberechnern auf 12-Bit-Basis.
12-Bit-Streiter.
12-Bit-Streiter?
Alle Exoten.
Einfach konnte ich die Dinge richtig programmieren. Und interessanterweise war es so, dass diese Anlagen, die von Verschieber gekommen sind, auch auf Z 80 Rechner, mit Z 80 Rechnern zu kriegen gewesen waren damals, aber die waren etwas teurer.
Und da hat der Außenhandel damals gesagt, ne, sparen wir, wir kaufen lieber die 12-Bit-Technik, das ist billiger und war aber nicht kompatibel, nach nirgendwo hin. Und dann haben wir dann im Rahmen so eine Rationalisierung, die Dinge auf Z 80 Rechner umgestreckt und als Kern haben wir dafür die Z 1013 Rechner benutzt.
Die 01 Wende mit dem statischen Speicher, die für die Industrie gebaut wurde, ne?
Ne, ne, ne, das war eine spezielle, modifizierte Variante, da haben wir dann mit Robotron und Risa, eine spezielle Variante war das, da haben wir dann mit Robotron und Risa die umgestreckt auf 64K, dynamische, und der hat dann auch noch ein einzig komfortables Betriebssystem drauf gekriegt.
Als normaler Mensch in der DDR musste man sich für so ein Z 1013 anmelden, da gab es eine Warteliste, wie für Autos, und es gab nur einen einzigen Lander, der in der DDR offiziell verkauft wurde, der war in Erfurt in so einem widerlichen Neubau. Da ist man dann so einmal mehr hingepilgelt und hat geguckt, wo denn nur sein Platz auf der Warteliste ist.
Hattest du dich da eingetragen?
Ja klar, natürlich.
Auf welchem Ort warst du dann?
Ich habe meinen ziemlich früh bekommen, ich hatte irgendwie ziemlich früh davon gehört und habe den dann bekommen, halt so zu spielen. War irgendwie ein nettes Gerät, das Problem war nur, dass diese mitgelieferte Folienflachtastatur, also die war noch nicht mal für Hex-Dumps-Abtippen im Entferntesten geeignet, dass man da kommt oder nichts mit tun?
Also da wir ja sehr viel mit diesen Dingen gemacht haben, da ist bei uns dann auch im WF dann so richtig so ein Club entstanden, wo dann also jeder, der irgendwie sich so eine Platine greifen konnte, die waren dann teilweise unbestückt oder nur zum Teil bestückt, die wurden dann noch richtig hochgerüstet und dann gab es dann irgendwelche Tastaturen aus einem anderen Betrieb wieder, die dann wieder getauscht wurden gegen LEDs, die wir uns dann reingeholt haben.
Ihr hattet natürlich gute Tauschwaren, wenn ihr LEDs hattet.
Ja, die LEDs waren gute Tauschware.
Das war immer interessant. Damit haben wir auch einen Risa ganz toll.
Da sind wir hin und die haben also ZC13 Platinen da gehabt, aber das lief alles nicht so richtig.
Und dann dachten die, ja Mensch, ihr wollt ja Lichtschachtbauelemente und VQC10, das war ja diese Punktmatrix, die damals in der DDR fertig wurden, waren natürlich kaum zu kriegen, weil wir sind ja auch nicht mit der Fertigung nachgekommen und konnten damit auch nicht stecken. Aber na gut, für besondere Kunden gab es dann immer noch mal ein paar Stück.
So funktioniert im Wesentlichen die DDR-Computerindustrie. Also ich hab mal mit jemanden gesprochen, der war bei Robotron irgendwie für Bauelementebeschaffung innen zuständig. Und also wenn man heute so einen super gestressten Manager sieht oder so, der sah halt schon damals irgendwie so aus. Der ist halt wirklich durch die Lande gefahren und hat halt irgendwie eine Zuteilung Personalcomputer gegen irgendwelche Schaltkreise gedealt und so. Also das war wirklich unglaublich.
Total exotisch, ja.
Aber stark war eben, dass wir diese Zerfbit-Technik dort eben von Toshiba so fast ausrutet haben mit so einem Ollen Z 80 DDR-Rechner.
Und das lief naja sogar richtig.
Aber dann kam die Wende und dann war abrupt Ende.
Naja, so war das ja. Da haben wir übrigens sowieso so, dass die meisten schicken DDR-Computer sind erst kurz vor oder sogar noch kurz nach der Wende rausgekommen. Da gab es dann eine Flut von Modellen. Da gab es dann einen CPC 664 oder 464 Nachbau. Kc Kompakt hieß der, ne? Naja, der sah sogar schon richtig aus wie ein richtiger Heimcomputer. Und dann gab es noch diesen Bildungskomputer, diesen BIC, das war auch so ein aufgebohrter Z 80 Rechner, auf den sie noch so einen Grafikkontroller raufgelötet hatten. Mit dem habe ich irgendwie auch nach Schule gearbeitet. Das war irgendwie doch schon eine interessante Erfahrung zu sehen, dass man tatsächlich bunte Grafiken mit so einem Ostcomputer machen kann.
Entschuldigung, ich habe noch mal den Namen falsch gemacht.
Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt einen schönen Abschluss hier für diese Sendung über Osttechnologie, nämlich von Guido23 erzählt etwas über die DDR- und Disko-Lichtanlagen.
Ja, natürlich. Ja, ich wollte noch etwas erzählen, dass wir damals immer schön, also wie gesagt, Diskoanlagen zusammengelötet haben, Lichtanlagen, also klassische Lichtorgeln, immer schön aus dem Funkamateur, oder auch diese Disko-Kugeln schön gebastelt haben aus Spiegeln, die wir uns auseinander, also verschnittenen Spiegeln und dann auf den Ball aufgeklebt und sowas gemacht haben, und dass das auch immer einen guten Absatz gebracht hat.
Ach, die habt ihr dann verscheuert?
Ja, einmal für unsere normale Schildisco, wo das immer gern gesehen war, und dann eben so eine Sache auch gemacht, oder hier diese Schlauch, aus Melkschlauch, so Fittenlampen rein gemacht, und da Lauflichter draus gemacht.
So Fittenlampen auf Drähte gelötet, die dann da eingezogen?
Ja, ja, und dann irgendwie versucht, die da reinzufädeln und das dann so zu machen.
Was musste man denn bei euch hinlegen für eine, sagen wir mal, 3-Kanal Lichtorgel?
Ach, das war unterschiedlich.
Das war ja dann mehr auf Tauschbasis.
Was weiß ich, will ich auch mal wieder von irgendeinem Kassettenrecorder gekriegt oder irgendwie sowas. Also einen der Stereo irgendwie ging, noch bevor es... also bevor diese, diese... Wie heißen die?
Die SKR 700 rauskam.
Da gab es ja nur diese kleinen KR 650 oder so. Wissen die so? Weiß ich gar nicht mehr. Die es immer zur Jugendfeier gab.
Da gab es den GeraCode in Stereo, genau. Der Monolautsprecher hatte aber einen Stereo.
Eben, eben. Und mit dem konnte man dann immer gut zum Disco machen. War das dann immer gut.
Jedenfalls für das Schuldespo.
Naja, stimmt. Die GeraCodes hatten dann tatsächlich so eine eigene Berühmtheit, weil sie waren so die einzigen Geräte, die qualitativ geeignet waren, um da Computerprogramme drauf aufzuzeichnen. Von den Ausgeräten, deswegen waren die ziemlich begehrt. Dann haben die dann irgendwann so eine speziell für den Computer angepasste Datasettenserie produziert, so in modernem Hellgrau. Und die Dinger waren so furchterregend, also damit konnte man es tatsächlich nicht hinkriegen.
Total aus Plaste und ohne Lautsprecher, dafür mit einer Leuchtiode drin oder so.
Genau, und irgendwie die Qualität war so verheerend, also dass man seine Programme, die immer mühsam auf dem GeraCode immer auf neue Kasetten kopiert hatte, wenn die alten schon zu weit runtergeleiert waren, die hat mein Name gar nicht eingelesen bekommen.
Gilo, was machst du denn nur heute?
Ja, heute höre ich Radio.
Nee, ich meine jetzt nicht heute als Tag, sondern...
Ich studiere E-Technik.
Also du bist doch da auch in dem Bereich geblieben.
Ich bin dabei, erstmal.
Mal sehen.
Du, ich hätte mal noch eine Frage. Und zwar, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch einer weiß, also das gab doch diesen A 7100.
Das war so ein, na, was auch immer, mit CPK-Betriebssystem.
Ja, so ein CPM 86, nachgebautes.
Ja, irgendwie sowas. Und ich hatte so ein Ding, bis vor kurzem noch gehabt, und hab da eine mühevolle Arbeit auf, mit diesen V-Base-Dings da, meine CD-Sammlung immer verwaltet und gemacht und getan, mit das Gerät kaputtgegangen, und ich krieg die Diskette nicht mehr lesen.
Naja, da hast du ein richtiges Problem am Hals. Also, weil 71.0.0... Ja, ja, das kann nicht dunkel werden. Das war schon ein Problem zu DDR-Zeiten, das Kettenformel 71.0.0.
Also, es gab für ein XT ein Programm, das konnte diese ganzen Formate lesen. Das konnte auch die ganzen CPM 76 mit 40, 30, 38, 60 Spuren und so weiter lesen. Ich weiß leider nicht mehr, wie das heißt, oder wo man das herkriegt.
Also, das war total schon ein Problem, ein 5, 25 Zolles Kettenlauffer im Laden zu kaufen. Also, ich muss sozusagen keine Daten schnell reppen.
Es gibt einen professionellen Markt für sowas, aber das würde wahrscheinlich teuer werden.
Das ist die sogenannte Datenarchäologie. Hast du noch einen 70-00?
Vino, verfügst du über E-Mail?
Ich habe E-Mail, ja.
Dann schick uns doch an chaos.orb.de vielleicht eine E-Mail. Und wenn irgendjemand dir da helfen kann, soll er uns auch eine E-Mail schicken.
Dann bringen wir euch irgendwie zusammen.
Genau, dafür sind solche Sachen ja schließlich da.
Danke dir, tschau.
So, ist fast vorbei.
Ab eins gibt es hier Mayday. Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt noch ein bisschen Abschlussplauderei machen, haben wir dann noch eins für ein Song Zeit. Was wollten wir dann da hören? Feeling B?
Nee, Schleimkern?
Nee, Possenspiel.
Ok, leg ich schon mal ein.
Ja, eigentlich müssten wir jetzt hier irgendwie die Adressen und sonstige Kontaktdaten ansahlen, aber da war Anni halt unseren mobilen Chaos-Adressen-Speicher nicht dabei. Da können wir halt nur sagen www.ccc.de, da finden sich eigentlich alle Informationen über den Chaos Computer Club Hamburg, den Chaos Computer Club Berlin, T-Shirts, CDs und was wir sonst noch so im Angebot haben.
Genau, die Hackerbibel wird ja immer wieder gerne nachgefragt und es gibt eine gute Nachricht. Irgendjemand hat sich viel Arbeit gemacht, hat die Hackerbibeln 1 und 2 eingescannt und demnächst wird auf CD-ROM die Hackerbibel verfügbar sein.
Plus viele andere Dokumente, die mit der Geschichte des Chaos Computer Clubs zu tun haben und interessant sind.
Vielleicht können wir da mal ein paar verlosen hier.
Bestimmt können wir das tun. Wie gesagt, wie wccc.de, da findet ihr Telefonnummer, E-Mail, Adressen, Ansprechpartner usw. Da gibt es auch die Chaos News, also Presseerklärung usw. und neue Informationen zu unserem lieben Innenminister und seiner Initiative, Verschlüsselung verbieten zu wollen.
Jetzt habe ich abschließend nochmal an den einzelnen von euch die Frage, was gibt es außer Computern, so an DDR-Technik, die ihr noch bei euch stehen habt?
Wirklich nix auf jeden Fall. Es gibt den RG 28 und so. Und die gab es meistens in zwei Varianten, nein, drei Varianten. An und aus war die erste Variante, dann dreistufig schaltbar war die zweite Variante und dann die Deluxe-Variante mit stufenloser Drehzweigregelung. Und den habe ich immer noch und der tut wirklich immer noch.
Das stand dann, glaube ich, elektronisch drauf, oder?
Genau, ja, Elektronik stand da, oder?
Es gab noch ein recht interessantes Produkt, das habe ich zwar nicht mehr zu Hause, das war der erste und, glaube ich, einziger Anrufbeantworter in der DDR. Und zwar war das Gerät ungefähr so groß wie ein A4-Blatt, vielleicht zehn Zentimeter hoch, ein bisschen kleiner, acht Zentimeter hoch, und war halt ein reines Ansagegerät. Also nach dreimal Klingeln kam dann halt die Ansage und man konnte das Gerät, was übrigens 1250 DDR-Mark gekostet hat, auch nur dann optional erweitern mit einem Kassettenrekorder, den man daneben stellte, der die Aufnahmemöglichkeit hatte, dann konnten sozusagen nach dem Signalton dann auch die Sprüche des Anrufenden aufgenommen werden. Aber das kostete dann halt nochmal, was hat denn der Rekord gekostet? Nur ein tausend herum. Also das komplett ausgebaute System hat dann für um die 2000 Mark gekauft.
Also ich habe mir diesen Anrufbeantworter nach der Wende ungefähr 35 Mark gekauft. Und ich hatte den zwei Jahre irgendwie kontinuierlich im Einsatz mit dem Rekorder drunter, bis der Staub so dicht drin war, dass er irgendwie stehen blieb.
Habt ihr euch noch irgendwelche Tipps zur DDR Elektronik?
Ich habe einen SR1 jahrelang betrieben.
Was ist das?
Schultaschen habe ich.
Ja genau, der Schultaschen.
Der war sehr robust, man konnte darauf rumtreten, man konnte entgegen die Wand werfen, entgegen nicht kaputt.
Genau, die Zielwanderung ist glaube ich MR 609.
601, oder?
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Wollen wir uns jetzt nicht drüberreden.
Dann sitzen bleiben natürlich die unvergessenen RFT-Anlagen mit dem krude programmierbaren Timer bei dem selbst der SS-Ingenieur nicht in der Lage ist, die Wegzeit richtig anzuwählen.
Genau, das ist immer logisch toll.
Was ist denn das Thema im nächsten Monat? Wie immer Chaosradio am letzten Mittwoch des Monats.
Ja, www.ccc.de-schräg-strich-chaos-radio. Ich weiß nicht genau, welches Thema wir...
War es nicht der virtuelle Kaffeeklatsch?
Ich glaube, es wurde ein Kaffeeklatsch vorgeschlagen. Aber er hat mir glaube ich nicht erzählt, was er sich darunter vorstellt. Aber es wurde rechtzeitig bekannt gegeben. Es gibt auch den Chaosradio-Ticker. Der per E-Mail zu erreichen ist, den man subscriben kann. Und dort kommen halt immer jeweils die Ankündigungen zum aktuellen Chaosradio plus Hintergrundinformationen.
Das war es, Chaosradio im April.
Ja genau, gerade so noch.
1. Mai ist nämlich heute. Deswegen war das der letzte Mittwoch im April. Vielen Dank an euch und vielen Dank natürlich auch an alle, die anrufen haben. Und an alle, die zugehört haben. Das war der Chaos Computer Club. Ich bin Johnny und ich sage tschüss, gleich gibt es Mayday. Falsche Nummer. Ein bisschen die 2 Formel Day.
The Crazy World, da Fritz präsentiert. Sonic Empire, die zwölfte Mayday in Dortmund. Sonic Empire, die Creme der Techno DJs und Live Eggs in der größten Halle Deutschlands. Sonic Empire, eigentlich ziemlich weit weg und trotzdem bei euch im Radio. Sonic Empire, die zwölfte Mayday in der Nacht zum ersten Mal von 1 bis 6 Uhr. Wenn Mayday live im Radio, dann nur auf Ritz.
Genau, da schalten wir jetzt rüber zur Westbahnhalle Dortmund, der zwölfte Mayday, Sonic Empire. Zurzeit legt Markus Löffel auf, der ist besser bekannt als den Namen Mark Spoon und danach erfahrt ihr alles weitere von den Moderatoren Stefan Laag von 1Live und Jörg Albrecht von HR3.
Ich würde sagen, May Day ist diesmal wieder der absolute Hammer.